So früh ist es gerade, ich bin eine Stunde wach schon, aber es kommt mir so voll, dass
bin ich gerade erst aufgestanden.
Mag wahrscheinlich sein, weil ich einmal im Ohr gekreinet habe gestern, aber bin ich
ja mal gewöhnt.
Boomerbettge.
Ja mal gucken, bis Twitch gecheckt hat, dass das Streamonline ist.
Moin.
Okay anscheinend hat Twitch mittlerweile mitgekriegt.
Weiß man nicht, letztens habe ich den Stream angemacht und es ist einfach gar nichts passiert,
obwohl OBS angezeigt hat, dass der Streamonline ist.
Alles richtig so.
Also da kann man sich nicht wirklich drauf verlassen.
Ich bin seit einer Stunde ungefähr wach.
Recht, recht genau.
So.
so ja gibt es irgendwas spannendes war irgendwas habe ich irgendwas verpasst
die woche ich war recht beschäftigt mit bewerbung mit jobsuche mit mmo crying
gestern mit neuem rechner bestellen mit neuem rechner zusammenbauen mit
steuererklärung machen ich mache nicht die steuererklärung ich mache nur teile
der steuererklärung schicken wir einen steuerberater
komm wir gucken mal kurz ja gestern sieben stunden oder so am stück github trending gucken wir uns mal an
gucken wir uns mal kurz an warum ist das warum ist das nicht dark mode weil ich den falschen browser auf hab
zeig mal kurz was was trennen denn die woche mal schnell schnell blick ok stable diffusions war klar whisper cc ai gedürnt go ai ai
offensiv google framework ach das ist irgendeine maschine learning zeug oder
netflix eigenes kubernetes keine ahnung ein universal android die plotop written in rust
ganz wichtig leute es ist es ist unglaublich wichtig dass in einem projekt wenn es in rust
programmiert ist immer schon im projekt titel steht written in rust und am besten wie gesagt
wir kennen sie alle blazingly fast und die rakete dahinter das raketen emoji ok nix nix spannendes
dabei das haben wir jetzt hier ups alles klar also wissen wir auch was auf github trennen
nichts was mich großartig interessiert echt ätzend sagt isa oder itsa mache momentan eine
umschulung zum anwendungsentwickler ok sollte jetzt eigentlich seit einer woche in der umschule
sein finde einfach keine firma wo ich seit 13 monat ja ich kenne noch jemand wobei ich gar nicht
weiß ob der jetzt schon eins gefunden hat also cool ich also drei ecken ja bekam drei ecken bekannter
also quasi der ist wirklich um drei ecken bekannter das überlegen wie der man von der tochter von
der freundin von meiner mutter das wirklich drei drei ecken der macht auch keine umschulung der
war der war vorher grüstbauer oder irgendwie sowas glaube ich zumindest den hat auch das
arbeitsamt in eine schulung gesteckt zum fahrer zum fahr informatik anwendungsentwicklung und der
findet auch kein praktikum und ich habe versucht den bei uns unterzubringen aber unsere personalabteilung
beziehungsweise ausbildungsabteil hat es mal wieder nicht hingekriegt der laden ist wirklich so
richtig krasser boomer verein was das angeht auf der einen seite heulen sie rum dass sie keine
leute finden da präsentierst du ihnen quasi auf dem serviert heller leute die sie sich auch
danach sichern können und kriegen sich hin ich musste irgendwie fünf mal nachfragen am ende
haben sie abgesagt weil sie sich nicht weiter mit mir beschäftigen wollten also also unser laden
ist keine ahnung da nimmt da nimmt keiner mehr sein zeug irgendwie ernst was er macht die
beschwerden auf der einen seite finden keine aber wenn sie dann die möglichkeit haben jemand zu
kriegen wollen sie nicht oder haben keinen bock sich damit zu beschäftigen und was ist
bei irgendwie ai whisper ist glaube ich ist das nicht tensor flow in c++ nachgebaut oder sowas
irgendwas in irgendwas in der richtung kam das gehäuse gestern noch an ja da kann ich mal was
zu erzählen also ich bin auf nummer sicher gegangen das also ich habe alles bei zwei also
ich habe die sachen bestellt bei amazon und bei equipper hießen die genau also ich habe so
aufgeteilt dass ich da möglichst wenig möglichst wenig shops habe kam auch alles an bis auf das
gehäuse das gehäuse gab es nämlich nirgends um erlieferbar also habe ich das über den hardware
shop über die ebay seite von einem hardware shop bestellt und nachdem es angeblich am zehnten
ankommen sollte aber die das immer noch quasi nicht richtig verschickt hatten bis zum neunten
habe ich mir gedacht weißt du was du bestellst das gehäuse einfach noch mal und schickst dann eins
davon zurück und jetzt ist der witz gestern kam natürlich beide gehäuse jetzt habe ich zwei mal
das meshify xl und im wohnzimmer stehen ist das halbe wohnzimmer voll quasi macht aber nichts
weil ich schicke einfach eins davon ungeöffnet zurück das können ja neue verkaufen das war
ja noch nie oft denn du darf dankeschön 20 monate hypersubscription hier nice zu
meshify xl giveaway ganz ehrlich ich würde ich würde das theoretisch sogar machen aber
der versand von so einem ding ist mir zu aufwendig ich würde nun ein giveaway machen wenn der
der gewinner mir quasi den pdf schickt mit einem fertig ausgefüllten versanddokument dass ich
noch drauf kleben muss und ich bin drl auto heim bestellen kann ihr wisst ich bin ultra faul so
was also für mich ist nicht die arbeit irgendwie das gewinnspiel zu machen sondern das zu
verschicken post zu gehen wobei man ja auch offiziell habe ich letzt hab ich irgendwann
mal vor jahren bei sollmecke gelernt das ist ja glaube ich zumindest das ist ja gar kein
gewinnspiel das ist ja offiziell eine auslobung weil man das ja nicht gewinnspiel nennen darf
weil gewinnspiel wäre ja quasi verboten weil glücksspiel oder irgendwas in der richtung
in der auslobung ist es ja der real razor chief ist am start vier monate dankeschön
für den sub wo wir gerade dabei sind wenn du der echte razor chef bist ich bräuchte
wahrscheinlich bald eine neue maus kann man da was machen razor chief ich hatte schon lange
keine razor mäuse mehr was dir was von aliexpress gesteht lutscher ist ok was eichshund muss
ich mal kurz gucken wie viele messages du sonst schon geschrieben hast ok du hast 341 messages
geschrieben du bist kein aliexpress spam das war ich nur auf nummer sicher gehen ich habe
deinen namen auch schon gesehen aber ich war mir nicht ganz sicher ich wollte jetzt nur
mal checken nicht dass irgendwie account so ähnlich heißt und irgendjemand spammt aliexpress
links oder sowas möchte werbung machen aber hat mal welche ist das eine intelligente lüt
station nicht einfach nur nur eine intelligente lüt die sieht irgendwie billig aus schweißen
tipps für smd wie willst du wie willst mit dem lütkolben smd machen oder ist da noch
heißluft dabei ist da heißluft dabei man sieht das jetzt hier nicht so richtig weil
damit macht kein smd gescheit aber gut die china chinesen schreiben da alles mögliche
dran excellent also ich habe ich habe ja seit jahren die hier er sah icon ich bin mir nicht
sicher ob ich pico oder nano hab die bisschen größere habe ich glaub Leute was ist größer
pico oder nano das ist schon viel zu feifert überhaupt die viel zu feifert die bezeichnung
ok hier also das teil habe ich seit einer ganzen weile bestimmt schon seit drei jahren
oder so jetzt ich habe das ganze weile vor corona gekauft ja und die finde ich wirklich
nice gerade halt auch dieses hand löt dieses dieses kleine sehr kleine lötkolben die die
bilder sind halt maximal unvorteilhaft gemacht weil man gar nicht so wirklich den vorteil
sieht das gute ist dass ihr super auch super flexible stromkabel hast das klein ist nur
mit auch kleine sachen machen kann es ohne so einen fetten kolben wenn der handtast gachi
bass gut aber es ist natürlich ist natürlich ein unterschied ob 200 irgendwas euro oder
97 wobei das ist aliexpress das kostet wahrscheinlich gar nicht 97 was kostet 97 ja doch geht eigentlich
was ist jetzt ok was jetzt der unterschied hier von schnelleres schnelleres löt das
ist die ganze station mit soldering tips naja gut ja aber ist auf jeden fall nicht verkehrt
ist auf jeden fall nicht verkehrt letztendlich kannst du fast alles dafür nehmen solang es
nicht durch brennt man kann auch den 14 euro all die lötkolben nehmen wobei das ding halt
einfach nur schwer und unhandlich ist und ein super starres kabel hat aber letztendlich
kann man ja alles mögliche geht ja irgendwie alles habt ihr schon mal regenrinnen zusammengelötet
das ist sixhead das macht man auch nicht mit lötkolben da braucht man so ein brenner
regenrinnen löten ja ja ja ne ne löten da brauchst du ein brenner lötzchen und ja
dann verteilst du deinen lötzchen ja das machst du dass es auch richtig schön dicht
ist oder ich muss ich die ganze zeit husen was ist das denn flussmittel ja für kleine
sachen also für elektronikteile ist flussmittel auf jeden fall was ich was ich empfehlen kann
ist was flussmittel angeht so ein flux fluxpen das trocknet es dann auch nicht so nicht so
schnell aus gut man kann auch so eine so eine tube nehmen oder so stift da ist da ist kleidmittel
flussmittel kleidmittel klingt ja nach ein bisschen was anderem flussmittel drinne dann
kann man also drüber pinseln mit dem stift und dann fließt das lötzchen besser brauchst
du heute im stream den pc fertig zusammen nein ich muss heute mmo kreinen keck wait
vielleicht baue ich die sachen auch ins gehäuse ein nicht im stream weil wir haben im prinzip
alles gesehen an komponenten ob es jetzt so spannend ist dass ich ins gehäuse einbau
oder nicht weiß ich nicht ob das so super interessant ist zu sehen wie ich die sachen
ins gehäuse einsetzte wichtig ist ich muss noch mal gucken ich habe ja gestern ein bisschen
übertaktet und also ich das höchste das höchste was ich eingestellt habe war 5,8 gigahertz
auf allen course welches mmo super old school shit ja 20 jahre altes game alter btf warum
sind schon 1300 leute heute morgen auf dem server an ja also ja genau also was mir aufgefallen
ich habe gestern bisschen übertaktet auf 5,8 gigahertz habe dann scenebench laufen lassen
da hatte ich hatte ich 41.350 oder sowas punkte dann also es lohnt sich nicht wirklich du
wärst dabei spielst du schon spielst spielst du gerade spielst du schon also ich bin schon
level fast level 30 jetzt heute 40 plus 50 vielleicht 50 je nachdem mal gucken wie gut
das mit den quests dann geht ab ab 35 ja genau zumindest was mir aufgefallen ist ich glaube
dass also ich muss vielleicht erstmal fertig den satz fertig machen ist aufgefallen wenn
ich prime 95 laufen lasse eine weile dann gibt es fehler allerdings auch im nicht übertakteten
zustand was mich zu zwei zu zwei sachen zwei zwei dinge annehmen lässt entweder übertaktet
das board standardmäßig durch irgendeinen bios setting also es gibt nicht wirklich instant
fehler wenn ich es irgendwie eine viertelstunde laufen lasse gibt es dann ab und zu mal auf
eins zwei course in fehler aber so jeden fall nicht 100 prozentig unter 100 prozent voll last
längere zeit fehlerfrei also entweder macht das board standardmäßig übertaktung und
ich muss es ausschalten um zu gucken ob es daran liegt oder ich takte mal ein bisschen
den ram runter den habe ich ja auch volle pulle laufen oder ich stelle mal das power
limit ein mal gucken im praktischen betrieb wird es wahrscheinlich keine großen auswirkungen
haben aber es sollte auf jeden fall nicht so sein oder was auch sein kann dass die spannungswandler
und das mainboard irgendwie alles mögliche zu warm werden ja ja hab alles dran weil da
ist ja kein richtiger airflow das steht zwar das steht zwar offen rum aber die dinger werden
ganz schön warm da pustet ja nichts drüber im gehäuse dürfte das besser funktionieren
gehäuse ist da ja alle beide gehäuse sind da also ich habe sie noch mal offen falls ich
falls ich gefragt werde ihr könnt auch ausrufe zeichen pc machen im chat das ist das das
ist die zusammenstellung die festplatte ist nicht exakt die die ich drin habe ich habe
die 14 die 14 terabyte festplatte drin aber exakt die bloß die 14 war ja 14 14 terabyte
weil die 14 terabyte gab es auf geiz halt ist irgendwie nicht zu sehen gab es nicht festplatte
mit ai was auch immer die für ein bullshit schreibe ich habe keine ahnung was sie uns
mit ai sagen wollen zumindest mal die festplatte außen vor kostet der spaß am ende so 4700
euro was halt der teuerste pc ist ever den ich mir gekauft habe aber dafür hat das ding
auch ordentlich power und reicht wahrscheinlich wieder eine weile wobei ich mich ja persönlich
freuen würde klingt jetzt vielleicht doof aber ich würde mich ja persönlich freuen
wenn er nicht so lange hält wie der aktuelle aber wahrscheinlich hält er länger als der
aktuelle weil das gleichermaßen bedeuten würde wir haben wieder ein bisschen fortschritt
was ja grafik und und features und leistung in games angeht alternativ können sie natürlich
auch sein dass sie die spiele einfach schlechter optimieren was wahrscheinlicher ist wieso
näher weil ich irgendwo beispielsweise auch video material drauf speichern muss wenn
ich beispielsweise also ich nehme ja videos wenn ich gameplay capture dann nehme ich das
meistens auf auf eine ssd dass es beim speichern nicht leckt oder sonst was aber die ssd hat
bloß 2 terabyte also ich habe noch eine externe ssd für sowas per usb aber ab und zu schiebe
ich die dann halt eben von der extern ssd auf eine große magnet festplatte wenn ich
die eine weile behalten will weil näher die ssd ist irgendwann auch mal voll hast du nur
eine hdd ja reicht also ich habe insgesamt dann die 2 terabyte on board also was ist
on board die 2 terabyte m2 ssd eine externe 2 terabyte ssd und die 16 terabyte magnet
oder 14 ist es bei mir 14 das reicht 1070 ti ja ich habe eine 1080 ti aktuell also ich
bin ja gerade noch vom alten rechner ja aber auch da wirds immer problematischer die sache
ist halt die mit meinem neuen rechner brauche ich auch unbedingt einen neuen monitor ich
spekuliere ja dass nächstes jahr noch mehrere oled 1440p 240hz rauskommen dann kaufe ich
mir so ein aktuell hatte nur lg ein angekündigt bzw halt irgendwas mit sagen wir mal so maximal
27 zoll der nast ist nass doch das gibt es immer noch das macht nicht nur nass hat auch
ein paar andere services drauf laufen aber trotzdem angenehmer man hat sogar lokal schnell
hingeschoben und gut ist gerade wenn man gerade wenn man online spielt und will im hintergrund
kopieren ist die lokale platte einfach angenehmer als irgendwie übers netzwerk ja es sind es
sind einige wie gesagt ich will keinen irgendwie 45 zoll bildschirm oder sowas wie willst
du was auf dem schreibtisch stellen ordentlich ne gibts nicht also nicht in oled variante
und nicht in klein außerdem hat es bei 1440p 27 zoll klar du wirst den unterschied irgendwo
sehen aber ist jetzt nicht so das macht wahnsinn viel aus ja was machst du damit also wozu
braucht man 90 terabyte also ich habe ihm das jetzt ungefähr habe ich denn da keine
ahnung 20 oder so 20 terabyte nutzbar das reicht habe ich im ansatzweise voll warum
kein rate 5 für die sata ssd bilden ich mache doch kein rate zwischen der on board super
schnellen m2 und der extern usb usb ssd
da lohnt sich das wirklich kann ich mir gar nicht vorstellen
schreib also quasi jolo jolo jolo rate sie kann sie wieder nicht entscheiden welcher lautstärke
es laufen will
welches reich mit gar wie gesagt schütter fast level 30 guck mal wenn du eben anfängst
guck dir erstmal das wiki an wo es welche quests gibt du also musst das du musst das
tutorial machen bis level 10 und dann am besten so ist dir paar leute für quests oder gehst
ins bg
schia preis ist momentan loll wie sie das denn schia ent die schia coin sollte ich wahrscheinlich
kurz grafiken
der ist ja mal bis sie machte ich wenn wir gerade dabei sind not stonks
ohne kost naja du musst dir dann solar panel erstmal anschaffen du musstest dir die hardware
anschaffen
bitcoin ist auch noch stonks
ich überlege gerade gibt es sonst noch irgendwas spannendes was also leute ich muss ja echt
sagen das hätte es früher bei mir nicht gegeben letzte woche pc bestellt teile mittlerweile
geliefert gehäuse mittlerweile geliefert und ich habe ihn gestern nicht zusammengebaut
weil ich was anderes machen wollte das hätte es früher nicht gegeben ich hätte früher
nicht alles komplett stehen und liegen gelassen in eurem pc gebaut und gestern morgen aller
gestern morgen habe ich den schock des jahrhunderts erlebt wir hatten noch hier im stream ich
habe es ja schon auf twitter geschrieben aber wir haben noch hier im stream den rechner
zusammengebaut also ohne ohne gehäuse ja also wir haben den kram hier zusammengebaut guck
mal hier so und so wie hier guck mal so wie hier habe ich das einfach liegen lassen und
ab den stecker rausgezogen also nix ich habe ich habe wirklich nichts nichts nichts gemacht
es ist einfach so liegen geblieben und ich habe den stecker rausgezogen und am morgen
habe ich ein bisschen steuererklärung gemacht und dann dachte ich mir so nach dem mittag
essen machst du das ding mal an und übertakt das ist ein bisschen dann habe ich den strom
rein gemacht dass die die rgb leds auf mainboard haben kurz geplinkt und ich habe auf den auf
den knopf gedrückt zum starten nicht der hier der da unten den man gerade nicht sieht
den knopf zum starten gedrückt vom mainboard und was war nix die kiste geht nicht an
habe ich aber strom rausgemacht noch mal strom reingemacht drauf gedrückt die kiste geht
nicht an oft noch mal auf den knopf gedrückt fest auf den knopf gedrückt
musiktime ja war gut und habe ich gedacht okay wartest du mal kurz vielleicht macht
er irgendwie ein test oder so weil strom weg war keine ahnung fünf minuten später noch
mal drauf geht nicht und da habe ich mir gedacht was hast du denn gemacht war irgendwas okay
ich habe das mainboard zwei zentimeter oder so nach links und rechts bewegt aber das kann
es ja wohl kaum gewesen sein was ist denn das warum geht das nicht an so und früher
wäre jetzt der punkt gewesen wo ich mega panik gekriegt hätte dass 5000 euro in sand gesetzt
habe und jetzt erst mal drei woche drei wochen die bank muss was kaputt ist und so aber ich
habe keine panik gekriegt das habe ich auch gedacht ich habe auch gedacht habe ich habe
ich irgendwie war ich statisch aufgeladen und hab hab irgendwie an ans mainboard gegriffen
hab kaputt gemacht oder so was mich ja ganz zuversichtlich gestimmt hat ist also ich habe
dann mich der reihe nach herangetastet ja also netzwerk und so war auch nicht netzwerk netzteil
stecker war drin war auch angeschaltet und so alles gut wie gesagt die leds sind sondern
habe ich mir gedacht okay jetzt probierst du mal was dann habe ich das netzwerk kabel
an den switch gesteckt und dann habe ich festgestellt aha das netzwerk kabel kriegt link auf dem
switch das bedeutet das mainboard hat prinzipiell strom und anscheinend auch allen nötigen
den es braucht weil ansonsten wird das netzwerk nicht angehen und wisst ihr was ich dann gemacht
habe ich habe mir gedacht okay was ist das aller simpelste was sein kann das aller simpelste
ist der power button auf dem mainboard ist kaputt ich habe übrigens auch den stecker
gewechselt und so mal andere steckdose reingesteckt hat alles nix gehabt vielleicht das schalter
auf dem mainboard kaputt kann ja sein also bin ich an schrank und ich habe noch von aus
einem gehäuse von vor 15 jahren oder so den habe ich wirklich der hat mehrere umzüge
überlebt mittlerweile ich habe noch nen schalter aus dem ural pc gehäuse also im prinzip einfach
nur nen knopf an zwei pins dran also zwei kabel mit nem power push button vorne drauf
und na überbrücken wollte ich das jetzt nicht das hätte ich auch machen können aber da
musste die pins treffen die teilweise recht eng beieinander sind dann habe ich den knopf
angeschlossen vom alten gehäuse weil mein neues gehäuse war noch nicht da drauf gedrückt
und es ging an so dann habe ich mir gedacht was ist denn das und dann ist mir aufgefallen
man kann diesen button mit mehreren funktionen belegen eines der funktionen ist ein ausschalten
eine andere funktion ist leds ein ausschalten und ich glaube dann gibt es noch direkt ins
bios starten ist die dritte funktion die man einstellen kann und ich dachte das mainboard
also der button ging einfach nicht auf mainboard und ich dachte durch das bios update ist wahrscheinlich
die funktion des power buttons geändert worden das konnte ich allerdings jetzt im nachhinein
nicht so wirklich nachvollziehen weil der power button ging danach wieder also ich habe
das dann eingeschaltet über den button über den quasi diesen zusatz button an den pins
habe ich eingeschaltet und dann habe ich während windaus mal drauf gedrückt und das ding hat
sich rebooted also im prinzip scheint er zu gehen was auch immer gut zu wissen dass es
nicht kaputt ist das war echt schock des jahrhunderts gestern habe ich gerade alter
wie kann das ding über nacht kaputt gegangen sein hat schicko darauf irgendwie gespielt
oder hat schicko was kaputt gemacht nacht aber ich meine was soll schicko auf dem mainboard
groß kaputt machen ja aber es funktioniert wieder da gestern noch ein bisschen overclocked
und dann mmo kreise grind gemacht bis 23 uhr so und was gibt es bei euch neues chat ich
habe jetzt ein bisschen erzählt das still feels amazing to play spellfield ja das ist
drei ja das ist ist das alba aus mountain oder so ja ja das ist das genau amont kill map wo
man ewig ewig und drei tage rennt best cheap cpu coolers da ist egal ich habe auch kein
chip cpu cooler ich habe einen fetten cpu cooler jetzt du bist jetzt vds zertifiziert nice ist
das ist das was für elektriker nee das ist vde vde ist ist elektriker was ist vds vor
enver dass wir unbedingt vor enver die designer specialist oder sowas was ist vds 420 ja wasserkühler
ja ein arctic cooling freezer 420 a rgb ist vde dann hast du auch schon das vera vde set
das elektriker vera vde kann dir jemand gute ressourcen für virtualisierung auf ubuntu
host empfehlen wozu brauchst du da ressourcen also das ist ja an sich jetzt relativ easy
du installierst qemo beziehungsweise qemo kvm machst wird manager auf und legst eine
vm an es hält sich hält sich ja durchaus in grenzen was man da machen muss reverse engineering
a broken calculator das ist zu das ist zu aber das ist zu 6 hat für den einstieg achso ja
dann gehts het gg ins du bist jetzt im letzten schritt des informatik schulms das heißt
du musst irgendwie deine bachelor arbeit schreiben oder deine master arbeit je nachdem was die
letzten schritte sind proxmox oder vmw hypervisor server mit zwei cpus und mit zwei cpus wie
viel kerne hat es denn mit zwei cpu kerne wirst nicht weit kommen und zwar aber wahrscheinlich
hast du dann eher was richtung 24 kerne oder sowas also ganz ehrlich es kommt drauf an
was du machen willst die antwort ist tatsächlich nicht so einfach also was was was spricht
gegen ubuntu server mit kvm da hast du zwar kein ordentlich hast zwar kein schönes web
interface und es ist kein virtualisierungs host der nur darauf ausgelegt ist aber du
kannst halt auf der ubuntu kiste noch selbst sachen machen bei proxmox kannst du höchstens
halt debian zu dem proxmox umwurscht ist aber auch nicht schön wenn du allerdings nur virtualisieren
wirst ist im heimbereich proxmox sicherlich nicht verkehrt wenn du was lernen willst
wo du mit vielleicht später auch mal geld verdienen kannst vom knowhow her dann das
da
für ein studium braucht man ein gymnasium abschluss oder was nicht unbedingt nicht unbedingt
prinzipiell ja aber es gibt schon in den allermeisten bundesländer in hessen ist es
auch so gibt es programme für und kurse und und zeug ich weiß ich habe ich mich nie genau
mit beschäftigt dass es auch mit realschule geht oder mit einer gewissen anzahl berufserfahrung
genau da musste man bei der uni gucken das geht prinzipiell ja das geht auch also in
hessen habe ich mal vor paar jahren geguckt da war das schon so und jetzt geht es bestimmt
auch noch noch einfacher gürtelstraße
ja gibt ja in deutschland verschiedenste möglichkeiten ja generell selbst selbst also mal angenommen
ich hätte das geilste abi aller Zeiten gemacht und würde jetzt studieren gehen ohne mist
ich habe so keinen plan mehr von vielen sachen
außerdem bin ich so richtig aus diesem lernen also aus diesem schulmäßig lernen crying
set raus und bin noch fauler als ich gewesen bin als ich in der schule war das gute ist
warum das bei mir im beruf trotzdem ganz gut funktioniert weil ich mich für die sachen
interessiere das ist halt das ding deswegen bin ich bei der arbeit meistens dabei also
auch recht engagiert weil es mich interessiert vieles in der schule hat mich halt so gar
nicht interessiert aber prinzipiell wie sag ich bin heute noch fauler als ich in der
schule gewesen bin und wisst ihr was das geile da dran ist mein opa hat früher immer gesagt
also ok da muss jetzt ein bisschen ausruhen aber das war so die standard antwort die standard
antwort von meinem opa ja ich kann mich noch dran erinnern also als ich noch ganz als ich
wirklich noch ganz ganz klein war und wenn ich dann irgendwie mal wieder meine fünf
minuten habe rumgeschrien habe oder irgendwie unbedingt was haben wollte und so halt was
kinder so machen ja so dann dann habe ich immer habe ich immer rum genervt und bei meinem
opa auf den keks gegangen und dann meinte der immer zu mir jaja warum ist die musik
eigentlich so laut da meinte der immer meinte meinte mein opa immer zu mir jaja warte mal
ab bis du in die schule kommst dann wirst du noch schwer kordeln nachgeben müssen also
das heißt das heißt auf auf deutsch so viel wie also korn bedeutet quasi schnur auf auf
hessisch damit du wirst quasi noch du wirst quasi noch öfters in die sind also er wollte
mir damit sagen du wirst dann später wenn du mal in die schule kommst noch viel mehr
situation erleben wo du nicht dein willen durchsetzen kannst das wollte mir mein opa
sagen also hat er erzählt als ich noch ganz klein war hat er immer gesagt warte mal ab
bis du in die schule kommst dann wirst du noch schwer korn nachgeben ist ok war nicht
der fall so dann hat er später hat er gesagt warte mal warte mal bis du in die weiterführende
schule gehst da wirst du noch schwer korn nachgehen müssen ich bin genauso faul geblieben
und habe genauso wenig zeug ok war auch nicht so dann war ich in der weiterführenden schule
kommst ja warte mal ab bis du eine ausbildung machst dann wirst du schwer korn nachgeben
wirst war immer noch so und das letzte leider leider ist er dann gestorben kurz nachdem
ich mit der ausbildung fertig war aber dann hat er gesagt warte mal ab bis du richtig
hart arbeiten musst dann wirst du auch noch schwer korn nachgeben müssen und ich bin
noch fauler geworden es ist das gegenteil der fall es ist das gegenteil der fall ich
bin noch fauler geworden das einzige warum das auf der arbeit wunderbar funktioniert
ist er denkt dass du keinen bock hast zu arbeiten er denkt dass ich keinen bock habe mich anzustrengen
da hat er auch recht dass die sache ist halt die ich streng mich nur gern in sachen an
die die mir gefallen und mich interessieren alles andere mache ich nicht auch auch manchmal
zu meinem nachteil ich habe ich habe ohne scheiß leute ich habe einmal vergessen rechnung
zu schreiben für youtube weil ich so faul war und es dann irgendwann vergessen habe
ich glaube da sind mir gut und gern bestimmt 1000 2000 euro durch die lappen gegangen weil
ich das erst zwei jahre später gemerkt habe ich habe mich mit zwei jahre später gemerkt
ich habe keine rechnung geschrieben für das ja cringe ja zwei jahren kannst du da auch
nicht mehr ankommen mittlerweile gab es den typ in der position gar nicht mehr mit dem
ich das damals besprochen habe deswegen bin ich froh dass ich jemand habe der sich ein
bisschen um organisatorischen sachen aktuell mit kümmert weil ansonsten kriege ich da
gar nichts gebacken was das angeht ich gerade mal kurz gucken muss hat matchmasters eigentlich
mittlerweile bezahlt sekunde muss man kurz bank bank app checken ok face id erkennt
mich schon mal mit headset das finde ich gut alle die haben immer noch nicht bezahlt man
muss ich da zum ersten mal in meinem leben eine mahnung schreiben
mal gucken post camp heute ist doch sonntag ja und die haben wir schon monatzeit gehabt
fast jetzt
tja also wie gesagt ich bin noch fauler geworden als damals in der schule das heißt studium
würde mir jetzt extrem schwerfallen das einzige warum es im job gut funktioniert ist weil
es mich eben noch interessiert was wir da machen
musik hört sich ein bisschen an wie babsi das triggert mich ok warum ja gut was heißt
warum bis jetzt hat es mir glaube ich nicht geschadet dass ich keins habe es sei denn
ich möchte in irgendwelchen behörden arbeiten oder so aber das habe ich eh nicht vor
musik
wie gehts mit meiner diät leute ich werde wahrscheinlich mein ziel verfehlen ich bin
immer noch so im gleichen bereich wie das was ich zuletzt gepostet habe auf der waage
das liegt daran ich laufe und bewege mich noch genauso viel aber ich fresse halt auch wieder
massig das heißt es bleibt jetzt es ist es ist quasi plus tages als das tagesform abhängig
es ist plus minus null mal ein bisschen weniger war minimal mehr also spielst du ab und zu
bed company 2 ganz ganz selten ja ich glaube ich habe es aber gerade nicht installiert
ne ich werde ich werde nicht zunehmen immer weihnachten ich bin jetzt ich habe jetzt
schon drei wochen urlaub und futter wieder und alles aber ich nehme nicht zu ich bewege
mich ja auch genug aber es reicht halt nicht mehr quasi nur nur das bewegen reich also
der form reicht halt nicht mehr alleine jetzt zum abnehmen wenn ich so viele wenn ich so
viel fresse ich gehe immer wandern immer ich habe gestern auch wenn aus elf beim wandern
gefunden guck hier no god no god please no
ok jetzt gehts jetzt ist der witz halt der witz hatte zu lange gebraucht ich habe gestern
wenn aus elf beim wandern gefunden und einer ist kein stock footage foto das habe ich gestern
selbst gemacht als ich das ding sehen gesehen habe wie es gedampft hat habe ich gedacht
ich muss es fotografieren und wenn aus elf witz machen nach dem stream vorgestern weil
genauso hat sich das gestern vorgestern angefühlt mit wenn aus elf da ist die kacke am dampfen
ja wenn aus elf ist genauso scheiße naja wenn aus elf hat ich bisher zumindest nicht das
problem wenn ich das netzwerkabel eingesteckt habe dass er sagt unbekanntes netzwerk und
sich keine dacp adresse holt das hat bisher immer funktioniert und beispielsweise kann
ich unter wenn aus zehn auch die tabs hier unten entgruppieren größte scheiß erfindung
ever zwangskopierte tabs tja dann musst du anders machen um das zu minimieren du musst
morgens aufs klo gehen morgens aufs klo gehen pinkeln alles was geht ausziehen und nicht
naggisch auf die waage stellen und dann sagen ach ist doch gar nicht so schlimm
ja aber da ist wahrscheinlich unser vde spezialist
luci besser der empfiehlt wahrscheinlich so ein fluke oder wie spricht man nicht aus
flug fluke 300 euro ding
ach so du willst kein multimeter du willst quasi ein so ein stecker also ich habe ich
habe also ein elv basic energy master basic so davon habe ich drei stück die funktionieren
ganz gut die hat wurden auch mal bei heise getestet und das war ganz nice davon habe
ich drei stück halt das ist da wo ich gestern auch den rechner mit fotografiert habe
also willst quasi messen für leistung dein rechner so zieht braucht beursacht wie ist
da die korrekte bezeichnung für
übrigens wenn es interessiert im eidl im eidl braucht der rechner 33 watt gerade habe
ich gerade gesehen im eidl und ich und noch nicht mal so richtig 100 prozentig eidl weil
ich hatte sachen sachen offen die sich aktualisiert haben und so was also das ist also sagen wir
mal 30 watt eidl mit der grafikkarte vielleicht ja 40 watt eidl oder so das ist vollkommen
in ordnung da kann da gehe ich wieder mal da gehe ich dacor das ist in ordnung wobei
es durchaus ein bisschen weniger sein könnte aber halt unter volllast nur die cp nur die
cpu bis zu 450 watt und wenn da noch die grafikkarte dabei kommt ist doch ganz gut dass ich 1000
watt netzteil reingepackt habe
wahrscheinlich hast du also entweder ist er sehr alt entweder ist er sehr alt oder du
hast keine keine energiespar modi an oder du hast dein windows auf volle power gestellt
oder so dass er nicht dass der keine siehst dass die cpu nicht in ihre seastates gehen
darf so viel verbraucht normalerweise im eidl keine aktuelle rechner es sei denn du hast
fünf platten drin die nicht da uns bin 1000 watt netzteil ja das ist für die kombination
früher haben die leute ihre netzteile immer krass überdimensioniert das ist die erste
generation wo ich sagen würde das ist jetzt richtig sinnvoll weil die 40 90 zieht massig
und die die cpu unter volllast halt auch ct max speed ok wie sieht das aus
naked achte ich dachte da liegt jetzt einer naked drin
aus könnt ihr ein netzteil empfehlen ja be quiet oder sie sonik finde ich persönlich
nice letztendlich kannst du alles nehmen solange sich lc power aus oder sowas wird das noch
schneller das ist ganz schön ganz schön am flutschen da machts kogas das ct nein ich
streben noch nicht mit dem neuen rechner da liegt noch neben mir
warntag unangekündigter wie kann man rausfinden ob es am netzteil liegt du schließt ein anderes
netzteil an und guckst ob es geht das dürfte das dürfte so die aller einfachste variante
sein deswegen habe ich immer noch ersatz netzteile rumfliegen wie läuft es mit dem vierer champ
da muss ich ich hatte die letzten tage unglaublich wenig zeit ich muss mich damit mal auseinandersetzen
weil ein paar leute erzählen dass manche sachen nicht gehen der hier hat beispielsweise vier
fiat us glaube ich amerikanischen fiat das funktioniert anscheinend richtig ja da gibt
es ein pull request wo ich nicht genau checken wofür er da ist hast du dir die game awards
angeschaut nein gucke ich mir seit jahren schon nicht an geht mir auch sonst wo vorbei
das so eine typische selbst feierveranstaltung geworden ohne wirklich irgendwie mehr wert
der print champ der macht aktuell gar nichts ok lassen wir uns eine runde level capci baiten
was hätten wir zur ausfall das gehalt als versicherungskauf man ow bw l kram ich sag
jetzt einfach mal dass es bw l kram ist irgendwas irgendwas in der richtung deine meinung zu
chat gpt da gucken wir uns gleich glaube ich auch noch ein video video zu an es ist beeindruckend
was das ding kann also ich glaube zwar nicht dass das passieren wird was alle channels
gerade irgendwie als titel haben so nach dem motto chat gpt macht uns überflüssig keiner
braucht mehr programmierer oder sowas das nicht aber schon beeindruckend was das jetzt
schon kann und der traum der manager wird wahrscheinlich war sie können selber anwendungen
webseiten design in dem sie bei chat gpt irgendwas reinschreiben das macht dann zwar
am ende nicht so genau das was sie wollen beziehungsweise verhält sich dann in irgendwelchen
edge case ist falsch aber sieht auf den ersten blick so aus ok also mit was wollen wir anfangen
wollen wir uns level capci baiten lassen oder gucken wir uns an was ein versicherungskauf
mann verdient kfz schäden sind seine aufgabe könnte es nicht irgendwas sein womit ich ahnung
von habe was interessieren mich kfz schäden hast du das gesehen ja habe ich habe ich habe
ich habe ich gesehen das das habe ich gesehen dass das hat nicht ganz hingehauen da stand
dann da stand dann auch so zeug drin wie lassen wir überlegen wie also erstens weiß der sprecher
das weiß man was hat mich hat mich verwirrt und ich muss noch kurz den rechner neu starten
oder irgendwas stand da drin das hatte wenig sinn machst du wieder ein stream über kack
programmier sprachen zu weihnachten weiß nicht ich kann dir das team deck nicht empfehlen
ich habe mein selbst ich habe mein selbst gebautes mein selbst gebautes team deck ich
habe mein eigenes team deck zumal ich dann die bilder auch selbst sehe
aber es verwenden so viele leute ich würde mal von ausgehen dass es an sich tatsächlich
was taugt dazu müsste ich erstmal ein bisschen benutzen
wie heißt nochmal das programm für die tablets keine ahnung welches programm ich verwende
auf dem tablet mein webinterface wenn überhaupt schon den neuen rechner aktiv nein der liegt
immer noch ausgepackt neben mir so wie wir es im letzten stream verlassen haben gehäuse
ist jetzt aber da okay wir gucken uns wir gucken uns an was was was man bei kfz was
man mit kfz schäden verdienen kann zeigt mal ja die videos gucke ich immer gern hoffentlich
haben sie nicht so viel tos musik wieder drin wann geht es weiter mit dem selbstbau pc wir
haben vor vorgestern vorgestern haben wir ja mehr oder weniger schon alles zusammen
gebaut ich müsste es jetzt noch ins gehäuse einbauen ich bin unschlüssig ob ich das
mit dem gehäuse einbauen auch wirklich im stream mache oder mich eine halbe stunde hinsetze
das schnell hier mache und dass ich weiter mmo kreiten kann aber ich muss es wahrscheinlich
wahrscheinlich wahrscheinlich baue ich im stream weil ich habe euch ja quasi mehr oder
weniger schon gesagt ich baue es im stream und ich kann jetzt ja schlecht sagen jungs
wir bauen es doch nicht im stream wir haben es zwar schon im stream gebaut aber ich meine
vielleicht will er der ein oder andere sehen wie ich es ins gehäuse einbauen mache ich
ja mache ich mich jetzt okay gucken wir uns mal an was verdient man als versicherungskaufer
wahrscheinlich zu viel nee wahrscheinlich über vielem zu wenig sie hat den schaden
gemeldet sie hat ihn auch verursacht und sie war natürlich darüber traurig also ich
würde man schon mal als folie das kann ich verstehen ich wäre auch traurig darüber
wenn mein auto eine beule hat es ist schon dann eine leichte haushaltung für mich trotzdem
sachlich und höflich zu bleiben die bekommen wir warum einfach immer denken einfach immer
denken ich werde für den scheiß hier bezahlt das denke ich mir auf der arbeit mittlerweile
auch wenn mich da irgendwas aufregt da ich gleich leute max ganz ruhig das muss sich
nicht aufregen weil du wirst dafür bezahlt und im zweifelsfall kannst ja auch einfach
am arsch vorbeigehen weil es betrifft dich persönlich nicht
gelten weihnachtsgeld und eine gewinnbeteiligung ja und das schmeckt das schmeckt mein namens
alterin kairan ich bin 23 gerard arbeite als versicherung und finanzkaufmann in köln
das schmeckt er hat aber auch schon das muss man sagen er hat diese typische versicherung
ich weiß klischee aber da hat diese typische versicherungskaufmann frisur wenn du mich
fragen würdest was für eine frisur versicherungskaufmann dann die in köln ich zahle die hälfte der
miete als unterstützung von meiner mutter wenn wir zu hause einkaufen zahle ich auch
gelegentlich habe ich auch gemacht und er könnte er könnte auch coaching videos auf
insta machen stimmt von der optik her wird es aufpassen über arbeit unverschämt
haben ich das richtig gesehen homeoffice alter die zukunft ist hier erstmal den schönen
winn aus 95 hintergrund hier der general hier wenn ich der hat nicht den reiter auf dem
hemm dann geht das ja nicht versicherungskaufmann bin denken die leute meistens ok vielleicht
will der mir was andrehen da höre ich auch manchmal dass die leute schon relativ schnell
getriggert er erkennt das an den du kannst mich schon gut versicherung verkaufen obwohl
ich gar keine versicherung verkaufte ich habe mein leben und die versicherung verkauft
wenn wir glück haben ruft sofort ein thema ich weiß nicht was mich erwartet da kann
alles kommen ist das endkundensupport sehe ich das richtig endkundensupport monka s das
ist ganz ganz schrecklich schwierig wird es eigentlich nur wenn man eine andere entscheidung
hat als die kunden sich wünschen was wahrscheinlich oft vorkommt und dann jemand anfängt halt
respektlos zu werden ok jetzt verstehe ich das auch ja also wenn ich täglich kundenkontakt
hätte und mich mit end also endjusern auseinandersetzen müsste dann könnte ich wahrscheinlich auch
nicht einfach nur sagen ich verdiene mein geld damit sondern das wird mich auch abfacken
habe ich euch das mal erzählt dass die öfters mal bei mir angerufen haben früher also ich
hatte früher öfters mal das vergnügen dass ich leute vom außendienst am telefon hatte
und warum naja weil ich als durchwahl 863 habe und 869 oder sowas oder oder 862 oder
irgendwie sowas ist die stelle wo sich die leute beschweren können wenn was mit ihrem
gehalt mit ihrer abrechnung nicht stimmt und ihr könnt euch vorstellen wenn die sich
verwählt haben sind sie immer super pissed weil wann rufen leute an also was was meint
ihr in welcher stimmung die leute sind wenn was mit ihrer abrechnung mit ihrem gehalt
nicht stimmt sind die da eher gut oder schlecht drauf also die meisten kann man kann man sagen
geben sich mühe netz drauf zu sein aber sind eigentlich schlecht drauf ja dann rufen irgendwelche
außendienstleute an und sagen ah meine provision stimmt nicht was sind da schon wieder los
dann muss ich sagen moment sie sind hier falsch ich kann ihnen da überhaupt nicht helfen
gehen sie mal zur 862 manchmal manchmal haben sie das erzählt so nach dem motto ja das sind
dann irgendwie keine ahnung 3000 euro 3300 also es ist teilweise schon richtig viel geld
was die in provision bekommen ist natürlich auch meistens dann über mehrere sachen und
nicht für einen vertrag aber da geht es ab also im außendienst provision technisch
kannst du richtig fette fette stonks machen musst aber halt seine seele verkauft haben
dafür und du musst der typ dafür sein egal gucken wir mal weiter zumindest seitdem wir
nur noch teams haben und keine richtigen telefonnummern mehr passiert das nicht mehr also doch wir
haben schon richtige telefonnummer noch aber da geht keiner mehr dran ich auch nicht aber
schon mal gut dass er homeoffice machen kann generale mit denen hatte ich auch schon öfters
mal was zu tun fall sofort an zum datenabgleich bitte einmal vorne nachnamen und die adresse
bitte vielen dank habe ich eigentlich untertitel an ich kann das nachvollziehen dass es für sie
ärgerlich ist habe ich auch volles verständnis dafür mitte schildern sie schildern sie das so
wie das entstanden ist bzw geschehen ist und wir würden das dann dementsprechend arbeiten dann
wissen sie bescheid dann wissen sie bescheid ich bin der immer noch abgefuckt aber sie hat ihn
auch verursacht das hat sie auch zugegeben und sie war natürlich darüber traurig weil sie ihren
schadenfreien rabatt verliert also sie wird zurück gestuft und ich konnte das nachvollziehen
ich habe das verstehen also dass man sich darüber aufregt und ärgert und die versuchen wir dann
runterzubringen runter zu holen und beruhigt zu erklären dass wir uns ungefähr kümmern dass
wir was sollen sie bitteschön was was genau bedeutet kümmern was sollen sie dann machen ich meine
die ist irgendeinem keine ahnung im kofferraum reingeprettert oder so so jetzt ist kaputt
der mein sie werden sie wohl sie werden jetzt ja kaum irgendwie ja also was sollen sie groß
mal ist ja schon passiert auch dementsprechend immer gut bezahlen ja bezahlen mein namen guten
tag kaira mein namen guten tag kaira mein namen guten tag kaira mein namen guten tag hi kaira
hier noch mal an meiner arbeit macht es mir spaß dass ich durch die schadenbearbeitung im kfz
bereich eigentlich unterschiedliche fälle habe natürlich auch ganz andere menschen vor wird mich
das abfacken den ganzen tag mit mit mit echten menschen vor allem vor allem quasi endkunden
telefonieren zu müssen das wird mich so richtig fertig machen da sieht man halt auch wie menschen
in solchen fällen auch reagieren das wird mich richtig gebeten bezüglich den abschleppkosten
wir können die abschlepprechnung für den versicherungen nicht erstatten richtig also
hätte der hätten wir hier noch ein restwert etc hätten wir es auch noch auszahlen können aber
der hat ja kein rest der ist ja komplett abgebrannt das fahrzeug nein können wir nicht zahlen es ist
meine aufgabe ich kann ja nicht einfach so geld verteilen da muss ich auch ablehnen das gehört
zu meinem job zumal der sich ja das er auch nicht persönlich zu herz er lehnt das ja nicht ab
er überbringt den leuten quasi die botschaft es wurde abgelehnt manchmal merken die kunden dass
ich auch etwas jünger bin und sagen dann ich möchte jemanden erfahreneres kompetenteres
sprechen dass ich da noch manchmal keine ahnung hätte dass ich das ich doch mal nachlesen muss
und reagieren dann noch extrem aggressiv also ich würde man schon mal als folie dort beschimpft da
muss sagen digga machst du auge und mir wurde gesagt dass ich dann jetzt meine chefin verbinden soll und
sage ich ja sie können gerne mit dem chef sprechen das ist gar kein problem uns wird auch auch
bedroht halt mit dem anwalt und so weiter wenn sie das jetzt nicht machen werde ich rechtliche
schritte einleiten soll er machen das das ist das gute in seiner position im kann das vollkommen
egal sein sollen die leute die verklagen also ich werde schon ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen sauer
es ist schon dann eine leichte haushaltung für mich trotzdem sachlich und höflich zu bleiben wenn
mich jemand anschreit sage ich direkt ich lasse mich von ihnen anschreien wir können gerne auf
einer höflichen und respektvollen weise weitersprechen ansonsten werde ich jetzt das gespräch beenden
moment das ist gar kein home office der muss quasi morgens vom bevor er ins büro fährt eine runde
hotline machen oder was oh mein dahin da hätte ich ja bock drauf alter ich fahre jetzt ins büro die
haben eine quote die wir erfüllen müssen 50 prozent der arme mann das ist ja und dann direkt
am aufstehen auch hotline stellst boar der arme der hätte ich keinen bock drauf stimmt dicken bmw war
doch klar doch doch doch doch ich weiß nicht irgendwie ist er bmw typ wie hat man das das
gesehen 2018 amitur ausbildungs- und kaufmann für versicherungen und finanzen versicherungskauf
also ja schulde für wirtschaft wirtschafts psychologie ok er hat auch festgestellt
diesen graben will er wahrscheinlich nicht sein ganzes leben lang machen wir erhalten mails diese
werden in eine akte eingespielt die zu einem schaden passen oder zugehörig sind und die arbeiten
ab wir haben hier ein anspruchsteller der sein fahrzeug repariert hat und uns dementsprechend
die rechnung eingereicht hat ich leite die mail an einen sachverständigen weiter der dafür
spezialisiert ist um zu schauen ob der schaden plausibel ist ich glaube das wäre mir zu
langweilig also ihr wisst ja vielleicht manche die öfters im stream sind ich habe selbst mal
eine kaufmännische ausbildung gemacht ich möchte aber mit bvl was das hier jetzt geben alter youtube
problem es geht nicht mehr weg
als gg hier sind wir stehen geblieben wir erhalten mails diese werden eingespielt die
zu einem schaden passen oder zugehörig sind ja also wie gesagt ich habe selbst mal eine
kaufmännische ausbildung gemacht aber habe ich abgebrochen und ich will heute mit bvl zeug
gar nichts zu tun habe ich habe ja auch ich habe die ausbildung auch bloß gemacht weil alle
damals auf mich eingeredet haben ich muss jetzt endlich mal was machen unter anderem mein opa
auch haben hier ein anspruchsteller der sein fahrzeug repariert hat und uns dementsprechend
die rechnung eingereicht hat ich leite die mail an einen sachverständigen weiter der dafür
spezialisiert ist um zu schauen ob der schaden plausibel ist und ob das vom schadenbild mit der
reparatur die in rechnung gestellt wird also er ist quasi sowas wie first level oder sowas
in der richtung also er macht das er bekommt quasi die anfragen hat endkunden kontakt aber
leitet das dann im endeffekt weiter und wie gesagt er entscheidet das ja nicht ob letztendlich das
übernommen wird oder ist quasi sowas wie first level entsprechend die berechtigte entschädigung auszahlen
also wir haben natürlich rückmeldungen da gab es auch schon sehr sehr nette worte auch an mich
halt mit sie sind super und ich finde das klasse wie schnell sie das bearbeitet haben und da freut
man hat das ja gar nicht bearbeitet aber gut das ist dem ja nicht klar der anruf noch nicht
wenn wir gleich was essen und ich gesehen echt natürlich freut mich das mit den kollegen
gemeinsam zu essen also zum mittag vor allem also ich muss ehrlich sagen das einzige was mir
wirklich gut gefällt wenn ich wenn ich nach frankfurt fahren muss und dort mal einen tag im
büro bin das einzige was mir wirklich gefällt ist mit zwei drei leuten runter die kartine zu
gehen mittags was zu fressen der rest der rest kann man komplett vergessen wenn man nur im
homeoffice dann auch davor gearbeitet hat ist es halt umso schöner dann nur mit den arbeitskollegen
abgesehen vom telefon auch mal so persönlich zu sprechen die sehen alle super business aus
jetzt typischer bwl am mittagessen smalltalk ich bearbeite jetzt einen teil casco schaden
wo die windschutzscheibe beschädigt worden ist ich trage als erstes datum ein und zu
prüfen ob das dann den schaden typ zu kategorisieren was für ein schaden jetzt vorliegt dann kommen
zu der ursache und später krasse job was da genau geschehen ist also ich will es jetzt nicht
schlecht drehen ich könnte das beispielsweise gar nicht machen ob alle unterhalte da aber da
hätte ich keinen bock drauf und falls da noch was fehlt fordern wir die an das muss man eben
tatsächlich zu gut halten beziehungsweise in video im vergleich zu vielen anderen videos wo nur
rumgeschwätzt wird arbeitet er den ganzen tag der morgens support gemacht wahrscheinlich wäre ich
schon nach zwei stunden support fertig gewesen für den tag also komplett nervlich am ende
ich bin mein gehalt zufrieden dadurch dass ich halt auch urlaubsgeld weihnachtsgeld und
mal gucken wie viel es am ende ist doppeltes gehalt ja und das schmeckt also das ist ja quasi das
maximale was geht jetzt zur vorlesung zu meiner uni also da dürfte schon noch ein bisschen was
gehen ich meine das sind 4 5 15 gehälter das heißt wenn man den bonus weg fällt das ist geiles
standbild das heißt wenn man den bonus weg fällt oder irgendjemand das also so der wahnsinn ist
es nicht jetzt zur vorlesung zu meiner uni und heute habe ich die technologische diagnostik weiß
man weiß man in welcher stadt das ist hat man das irgendwie irgendwie am anfang gehört
köln ok weil das bild könnte alles sein aber abends noch studieren da muss ich sagen hut ab
also ich hätte auch für vollzeit studium absolut kein ja kein kein keine motivation
mehr aber das abends noch zu machen ist wirklich nicht ohne hallo ich finde mein studium entspannt
wobei es ist ja wahrscheinlich mehr oder weniger einstiegsgehalt 49 kader ist das vollkommen in
ordnung ja es nutze ich sehr für mich ja ich bin ich bin gerade so im so am gucken was job
und gehalt angeht dass ich da gerade wahrscheinlich etwas andere vorstellungen habe versus quasi
direkt berufseinsteiger mein studium sehr interessant es nutze ich sehr für mich ich
habe auch sehr viele neue sachen durch gelernt und auch viele viele neue leute kennengelernt durch
das studium hallo zusammen mein arbeitgeber hat mir ein stipendium für das studium zur
verfügung gestellt es ist irgendwo eine hausforderung die ich auch so angenommen
habe jetzt von einem jahr es ist schon sehr stressig also ich sehe mich auch manchmal
nach den zeiten wo ich wirklich keinen stress hatte ich habe in der herrenbezirkssieger gespielt
da ist aktuell durch die arbeit sieht auch recht fit aus habe ich leider für das fußballtraining
nicht so viel zeit das macht jemand schon traurig vor allem weil ich seitdem ich fünf jahre alt bin
fußballspieler aber das ist halt die realität was ich mache da kann ich leider nicht nichts
dran ändern wir hatten auch mal ein azubi er kennt ich so gewisse parallel wir hatten auch mal
azubi der war auch fußballspieler und der hat auch am wochenende und so immer ja was ich so seine
seine was was keine ahnung welche liga fragt mich nicht ja da seine vereinsspiele gespielt und dem
hast du auch angemerkt er hat halt immer weniger zeit dafür gehabt und danach nachdem er bei uns
die ausbildung fertig gemacht hat ist er ist auch studieren gegangen hatte kein bock mehr auf den
kram dann bioinformatik studiert und mittlerweile ist er glaube ich mit fußball spielen auch
nichts mehr also schade eigentlich dass so viele dann die die wie soll ich sagen die der realität
einholt kann man nicht sagen so dass so dass das tägliche leben so in weg kommt ja weil
der hat bestimmt gerne fußball gespielt das ist auch für fitness wohlbefinden alles bestimmt das
beste was machen kannst aber du musst du bist so eingespannt bei fünf tagen in der woche wenn
du fünf tage die woche arbeitest plus wenn du quasi fünf tage die woche arbeitest plus abends noch
studieren gehst du kannst nichts machen und um 21 20 macht noch mal den giga chat das giga den
giga chat fitnessstudio crying deswegen ich kann all nur empfehlen die sich irgendwie leisten
können leute arbeitet teils seit vier tage die woche ist das beste was es gibt
ich gehe dreimal die woche ins fitnessstudio manchen machen sogar firmen
ein sehr guter freund einer meiner engsten mit dem ich regelmäßig zum trainen komme mit
goldkettchen das brimt tos musik jetzt wird erst mal giga chat transformation eingeleitet
ich muss die tos musik weg machen im büro oder in der uni sitzt ich trinke heute rücken
mal drücken beschweren entgegenzukommen die zu verhindern für die zukunft vor allem weil
ich auch kollegen habe die auch rückenbeschwerden haben ja vor drei wochen ungefähr habe ich mich
bei beim beintraining an den leisten verletzt gab es da nicht irgendwie das meme dass man
beinahe ich trainiere das hat auf jeden fall in der notaufnahme geendet also ich
hatte zwei wochen sportverbot aber ich denke ich bin schon wieder fit
was ist für musik brüt brüt brüt brüt was schrottmusik brüt als habe ich gar nicht geguckt
mal also was was gibt es hier insgesamt 2000 ich denke als berufszeitsteiger ist ja alles
voll voll voll klar das finde ich nice guck mal hier hat er noch einiges übrig gut ich meine
er muss keine miete bezahlen in dem sinn gerade in köln in stadt ist wahrscheinlich eine eigene
wohnung eine ganze ecke teurer das war nice ok ich meine so wirklich bock auf den job hätte
es jetzt nicht gemacht den ganzen tag also morgens zwei stunden hotline und danach
irgendwelche formulare ausfüllen wahrscheinlich ist das highlight für ihn am tag auch mit den
kollegen in die kantine zu gehen und eine runde zu futtern und und abends mit digger
und und bruder im fitnessstudio zu crime aber trotzdem als einstiegsgeil ist ganz ganz nice
aber was jetzt ein versicherungsangestellter macht weiß ich nicht so wirklich mein außer hotline
und und formulare ausfüllen ok vielleicht ist auch das was ein versicherungsangestellter
kaufmann für versicherung was auch immer genau den ganzen tag macht das ist aber nicht das was
ich mir so vorstelle was ich gerne machen würde der die die firma bezahlt irgendwas
dabei für für sein studium hat er erzählt ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja
ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja
Die Konfiguration ist nicht so einfach.
Also Router OS erschlägt dich erstmal richtig.
Du kannst ein Quick Setup machen.
Du kannst das Quick Setup verwenden, aber Router OS ist ein bisschen abenteuerlich zu
konfigurieren.
Also wenn du Quick Setup machst, willst du den Router auch verwenden zum Internet hin?
Also du kannst mit dem Quick Setup ein halbwegs sicheres Nutt-Szenario standardmäßig auswählen.
Da musst du ihm sagen, was der externe Port ist, was die internen Ports sind.
Das kannst du in diesem Quick Setup machen, nachdem du es gestartet hast.
Also wenn du das erste Mal startest, ist das Ding in so einem Schnelleinstellungs-Setup,
da kannst du das auswählen.
Danach musst du dich mal mit den einzelnen Punkten beschäftigen, das kann man so pauschal
nicht sagen.
Firewall ist allerdings tatsächlich relativ easy, so wie man sich das vorstellt.
Quelle, Ziel, Interface, Port, Deny, Accept, Reject, das was man so kennt.
Aber da lernst du auf jeden Fall ein bisschen was bei.
Ich würde es vielleicht nicht unbedingt gleich als produktiven Internetrouter bei mir daheim
verwenden, wenn ich nicht wüsste, was ich da mache, aber zum rumbasteln ist das Ding
sehr nice.
Direkt mit Warn ans Internet, ja das ist die Frage, was du für ein Modem hast.
So Kabelmodems ansteuern kann der nicht, das höchste der Gefühle ist, der kann DSL-PPPOE,
kann der glaube ich, können die Dinger, wenn du ein DSL-Modem hast, ansonsten machst du
halt deine Providerbox davor.
Welches Modell der 4090 hast du bestellt, mach mal Ausrufezeichen PC im Chat und dann
wirst du feststellen, dann kommst du bei dieser Liste hier raus und dann wirst du feststellen,
ich habe eine Zotec Gaming GeForce RTX 4090 Trinity OC bestellt, warum, hat keinen besonderen
Grund, einfach nur weil die gerade gut lieferbar ist und nicht übermäßig teuer gegenüber
den anderen, insgesamt selbstverständlich übermäßig, unsinnig teuer.
Guck mal, ich hab genau richtig bestellt, RAM nicht mehr lieferbar, Mainboard nicht
mehr lieferbar, genau richtig bestellt, Pogu, was ist PPPOE, das ist das worüber man sich
quasi einwählt bei DSL, das Protokoll, wo du dann Benutzername und Kennwort an die Telekom
übermittelst und dann dein DSL Modem die Verbindung herstellt oder das Modem dahinter,
welches Netzteil ist es nun geworden, wie gesagt das da, das ist die finale Liste hier,
das ist genau das was ich hier da hab, inklusive dem Kontaktframe und allem, jetzt haben alle
die PC-Configur auf, vielleicht hätte ich mal besser Ref-Links gemacht anstatt so einen
Guides-Halls-Link, erstmal Ref-Links, weil die einzigen die was davon haben ist Guides-Halls,
weil die bekommen bestimmt irgendwie Gebühren oder Affiliate Zeug, hast du dafür gespart?
Ne, aber ich nicht, ich geb einfach ansonsten relativ wenig Geld aus, so dass ich mir sowas
wenn ich mir was kaufen will einfach kaufen kann, ich geb für nix Geld aus normalerweise,
ich bin äußerst sparsam, nicht weil ich sage ich muss gezielt sparsam sein, ich bin an sich,
wie soll ich sagen, da sehr sehr genügsam, also ich hab wenig Bedarf da großartig Geld
auszugeben, ich flieg nicht regelmäßig in Urlaub oder solche Geschichten, ich kauf
nicht laufende neue Autos, ich lass mein Auto nicht tunen, ich hab keine Kinder, keine
Frau oder sonst was, die irgendwie was sich Kohle verschlingt, ich brauch kaum Geld, ja,
kein Trittwagen, ich kauf nicht laufend irgendwelchen Kleinkramen, den man gar nicht
braucht, dazu kommt, dass ich ganz ok auch verdiene, plus halt YouTube und Twitch noch dabei, ich
hab genug auf der hohen Kante, also wenn ich dann mal was kaufen will, kann ich halt auch kaufen.
Der Trick ist, einfach mehr Geld zu behalten als auszugeben und schon kann man sich ab und zu was
kaufen. So, was kommt uns als nächstes an? Hast du noch gefunden? Achso, Job? Ja, naja,
hab ich ja im letzten Video schon ein bisschen was zu erzählen, also einen hab ich direkt den Vertrag
zum Unterschreiben da, schon, aber es hat sich kurzfristig noch was ergeben, was ich nächste
Woche nochmal, der ich nächste Woche nochmal nachgehen muss. Ja, wirst du, ab jetzt keine
Schulden mehr mit diesem einfachen Trick. Der Trick, achja, stimmt Farmer, du hast recht,
jaja, das ist tatsächlich ein guter Trick, aber ich hab festgestellt, Fragen ob es Leute gibt mit
Prime ist taktisch, taktisch ungeschickt. Ich mein, außer die sind so nett wie Game Up und geben
direkt den Primes ab, also was viel besser ist, was viel besser ist, entweder du wartest auf den
Zeitpunkt, wo du eine gute Überleitung hast oder du erklärst den Leuten nochmal, dass wenn sie
Amazon Prime haben, dass man dann einen Streamer seiner Wahl kostenlos im Monat unterstützen kann
und dann muss man sagen, das ist ganz wichtig, ich hab gemerkt, das zieht richtig gut, aber ich hab
es erstmal gesagt, also ich hab es erst zum ersten Mal auch ohne Hintergedanken gesagt,
an mir ist auch gefallen, dass das gut zieht, aber es ist letztendlich auch so. Wichtig ist,
dass man seinen Prime-Sub ausgibt, es muss auch nicht bei mir sein. Letztendlich ist es auch
wirklich wurscht, ob ihr mir meinen Prime-Sub, äh, ob ihr mir euren Prime-Sub gibt oder jemand
anderes, ihr solltet bloß euren Prime-Sub nicht verfallen lassen, weil das ist blöd. Prime-Sub
verfallen ist quasi Überweisung, indirekt Überweisung an Bezos. Game Up und Zwerg-Cringer,
danke schön für den Sub. Aber das gefällt den Leuten, weil dann sagen die Leute, ah guck mal,
er weist uns ja nur darauf hin, dass man seinen Prime-Sub ausgeben soll und er sagt ja auch,
es muss nicht eher sein, das hab ich gemerkt, kommt gut an, aber es ist ja auch letztendlich so.
Aaron Jesus, danke schön für den Prime-Sub, aber es ist ja auch so. Prime-Sub, es ist eine
super Geschichte, gerade für Streamer, die vielleicht noch ein bisschen kleiner sind wie ich,
die trotzdem gerne guckt. Es ist nicht das Geld letztendlich, gerade bei Kleineren,
es ist glaube ich bei vielen Streamern auch die Motivation, die damit verbunden ist. Klar,
ich meine, wenn du jetzt hauptberuflicher Streamer bist, dann kommst du ohne Sub nicht über die
Runden. Aber ich denke gerade bei Kleineren, ob der jetzt quasi 5 Euro mehr im Monat kriegt oder nicht,
ja, wenn die 5 Sub im Monat bekommen oder so. Das ist jetzt nicht so, dass der davon jetzt große
Sprünge machen kann, aber die Motivation ist glaube ich das Ausschlaggebendere und das zeigt
auch kleineren Streamern so nach dem Motto, guck mal hier, ich guck dein Zeug gern und kleine
Streamer, die guten Content machen, die werden über kurz oder lang auch größer. Also auf Twitch
habe ich denke ich eine ganz gute Quote mittlerweile, aber auf YouTube hatte ich jahrelang wirklich eine
gute, wie soll ich sagen, gute Prediction. Also ich konnte eine ganze Zeit lang den Channel angucken
und Videos angucken und ich konnte dir sagen, okay, der Channel, der ist in einem Jahr oder zwei Jahren
ist der mega groß. Ich habe früher gerne, wie hieß der, Hey Aaron, glaube ich, hieß der,
ja, geguckt. Da hatte der noch irgendwie keine Ahnung, 8000, 8000 Subs oder so. Heute hat er
irgendwie 2 Millionen oder sowas. Und als ich das gesehen habe, ich wusste instant, der Channel wird
mal riesengroß. Es gibt viele Sachen, ja. Also die meisten Channels, die du dir anguckst und denkst,
ja, Alter, das sind aber wirklich gut gemachte Videos, da guckst du nach und nach drauf und
stellst fest, okay, die wachsen auch ordentlich. Es gibt wenig Channels jetzt, also mir fällt
spontan kein Channel ein, wo ich sagen würde, oh ja, den gucke ich gerne regelmäßig, die Videos
sind richtig gut gemacht und der wächst nicht. Natürlich ist wachsen immer so ein bisschen auch
eine Sache so des Genres, ja. Wenn ich mir irgendwelche Videos angucke für Webentwicklung,
Programmieren und sonst was, natürlich ist das jetzt nicht so die riesen Zielgruppe wie vielleicht
irgendwelche Funny Stream Compilations oder sowas. Basti Baro und Dankeschön für den Sub.
Naja, auf YouTube ist das Wichtigste, was du machen musst und das habe ich auch erst, ich meine,
ich mache es immer noch nicht gut, ja, ich mache es immer noch nicht gut. Eine gute Entscheidung
war wahrscheinlich jemand anzuheuern, der mir ein paar Thumbnails macht, aber ich glaube,
eines der, wie soll ich sagen, eines der, obwohl es jeder weiß, ich muss sagen, also ein Thema,
obwohl es jeder weiß, aber gerade Leute, die neu sind auf YouTube, es trotzdem nicht machen,
ist Folgendes. Die Leute machen ein Video, auch vielleicht ein ganz gutes Video und wollen das
möglichst schnell raushauen, weil sie ja wissen wollen, also sie wollen, jeder Content Creator
will, dass seine Videos gesehen werden. Das ist das hauptsächliche Ziel, zumindest das erste Mal,
wenn du mit YouTube anfängst. Die Leute wollen quasi Aufmerksamkeit und, und dass ihre Videos
gesehen werden. Das heißt, wenn du ein Video fertig hast, willst du es eigentlich möglichst
schnell hochladen und, und veröffentlichen, aber eigentlich ist es besser, es sei denn, es sei denn,
es ist was super Aktuelles, ja, also was, was wirklich gerade, was weiß ich, Microsoft kauft
Activision oder so, da kannst du nicht drei Tage warten. Aber manchmal ist es besser,
einen Tag zu warten und sich Gedanken zu machen um gute Titel und gute Thumbnails.
Das ist das erste, was jemand sieht, der das empfohlen bekommt und meine Thumbnails sind
auch noch verbesserungswürdig und Titel sicherlich auch, aber sich Gedanken machen über Thumbnails
und Titel, das ist mit Abstand das Wichtigste. Video, gutes Video dahinter zu haben, ist auch
wichtig, aber nicht 95 Prozent der Zeit auf die Videoerstellung verschwenden und dann
irgendeinen Thumbnail und Titel zusammenwurschen. Dann lieber noch einen Tag warten. Was ist mit
ihm? Du meinst, Algorithmen verstehen? Ich glaube, der kann dir alle Algorithmen erklären,
bloß den Twitch-Algorithmus, den YouTube-Algorithmus nicht. Ich will keinen Face-Reveal machen,
das ist richtig. Ich will keinen Face-Reveal machen, weil mich die Leute dann im Zug erkennen
würden. Der macht aber auch den harten Video-Crime, muss man sagen. Der haut wirklich täglich
da Videos raus. Oder was ist täglich? Mehrfach die Woche. Er gibt sich auch richtig Mühe
mit den Videos, also das ist tatsächlich Fulltime-Job bei ihm. Der vermarktet das auch gut, da
hat er sein Python-Buch am Start und so was. Finta macht das gut. Der hat halt das Karriere-Machen-Crime-Set,
Mindset. Ein Video zu Chat-GPT wäre interessant. Das gebe ich dir recht, wäre interessant.
Würde ich auch gerne gucken. Woher sollen Leute wissen, in welcher Stadt du wohnst?
Weil ich schon öfters erzählt habe. Das ist doch kein Geheimnis, wo ich wohne. Leute,
ich habe gestern gesehen, der Friseur spielt Modern Warfare 2. Habe ich gestern im Discord
gesehen. Habe ich mir gedacht, den müsste ich jetzt mal dazu anhauen und sagen, lasst
mal Video machen, wie 2010. Ja, es ist mehr oder weniger der letzte Stand im Video. Na
gut. Also, dann gucken wir uns mal ein Chat-GPT-Video an. Auf geht's. Warum Chat-GPT in die Welt
verändern wird? Wurdest du schon an einer Stimme erkannt? Ja, mich hat mal ein ehemaliger
Azubi an der Stimme erkannt. In HTML und JavaScript. Das wäre vor ein paar Jahren schon mal nicht
möglich gewesen. Vor ein paar Jahren war das höchste der Gefühle, dass man auf irgendwelchen
Support-Seiten mit irgendwelchen billigen Chatbots konfrontiert wurde, die einfach nur
im Prinzip so, if-else, if enthält die Frage diese Schlüsselwörter, dann schick ihm einen
Link auf unsere Hilfeseite an. Kennt ihr diese Support-Chatbots? Du bist auf irgendeiner Webseite
zu lang, unten links ploppt dann Alice auf oder so, blup, Alice, kann ich dir helfen?
Und dann denkst du, alter, geh mir nicht auf den Sack, JavaScript-Chatbot. Und wenn du
dann wirklich was fragst und wissen willst, kommst du vielleicht bei irgendeinem In da raus.
Könntest du machen, dass das alles schöner aussieht? Also eine völlig konkrete Frage,
aber trotzdem kriege ich daraufhin Code ausgespuckt, der ein tatsächlich schöneres
Ergebnis liefert. Aber jetzt wird es wirklich verrückt. Jetzt schreibe ich nämlich,
könntest du einen Kasten um die Geburtstagsabfrage machen und noch...
Das ist natürlich krass, wenn das Ding versteht, ne? Also der hat quasi gerade eine Frage auf
Deutsch in CSS übersetzt, beziehungsweise, ne ne, der stimmt so nicht. Er hat quasi erkannt,
dass du eine Frage bezüglich CSS-HTML-Styling gestellt hast und dann kriegt er auch noch raus,
welches einer Code Snippets dazu passt. Das ist schon heftig, oder?
Denn es stellt sich raus, dass die Website gar nicht funktioniert. Wenn ich das Ganze als
HTML abspeichere und in den Browser lade, wird nie das korrekte Alter berechnet,
da steht dann immer nur NAN. Okay. Was war das AI-Punkt? Ne. Wie war die Adresse? Ach,
Chat-Open-Punkt-AI. Ging das gestern nicht noch? Ohne Anmeldung? Hatten wir die Seite nicht gestern
oder so mal offen? Mit Handynummer? Na geil. Ist jemand eingeloggt? Ist ja jemand eingeloggt
von euch gerade? Haben wir noch irgendeinen Fake-Google-Account hier? Ne, Mist. Enter
E-Mail-Adress. Okay. Wartet mal. Was? Okay.
Alles klar. Naja, okay. Ich glaube, die erkennen, dass das eine Fake-E-Mail ist und schicken keine
Bestätigung, oder? Wahrscheinlich erkennen die das. Ich wollte Chat-KPT fragen. Wie geht man
als Streamer am besten mit Backseatern um? Falls einer eingeloggt ist, fragt ihn mal. Was mache
ich, was mache ich als Streamer am besten gegen Backseating? Spannend. Aha. Da sind wir doch.
First Name. Keck. Okay. Dann nicht. Ja, dann nicht.
Ja, das mache ich jetzt aber nicht. Dann nicht. Okay, also was sagen die? Als Streamer ist es
wichtig, offen und ehrlich, ne, ne, auf Deutsch, auf Deutsch wollte ich sagen. Okay. Als Streamer ist
es wichtig, offen und ehrlich, mit Backseatern umzugehen. Ach ja. Gut, mache ich ja. Ich
scheiße die Leute manchmal an, dass sie mir nicht auf den Sack gehen sollen. Aber das ist,
glaube ich, nicht so. Nicht die beste Variante. Okay. Als Streamer ist es wichtig, offen und
ehrlich, mit Backseatern umzugehen. Es kann hilfreich sein, ihnen zuzuhören und ihre Meinung
und Fragen zu berücksichtigen. Aber letztendlich liegt die Entscheidung über das Spielen und die
Art und Weise, wie es gespielt wird bei ihnen als Streamer. Ja, gut. Der hat halt gelernt,
dass beim Streaming es hauptsächlich gespielt wird. Wenn Backseater Kommentare stören und
unangemessen werden, können sie immer die Chatmoderation bitten, sie zu entfernen oder zu
sperren. Modcheck. Es ist auch in Ordnung, klar zu machen, dass sie die Kontrolle... Ach,
mehr kann man nicht machen. Es ist wichtig, dass Streamer immer höflich und respektvoll mit
Zuschauern umgehen. Im Prinzip stimme ich der Sache ja zu. Außer wenn es Leute sind,
die einen absichtlich die ganze Zeit nerven wollen. Auch wenn es manchmal schwierig sein kann,
mit Backseatern umzugehen, ein guter Weg, damit umzugehen ist es, sich im Vorfeld klare Regeln
für das Verhalten im Chat zu setzen und diese auch durchzusetzen. Es kann auch hilfreich sein,
ein Moderationsteam einsetzen, das im Chat auf die Einladung dieser Regel achtet und gegen
gegebenenfalls unangemessenen Fällen konsequent ahntet. Ja, exellent, jetzt weiß ich Bescheid,
das wusste ich vorher nicht. Sehr diplomatische Antwort, ja. Wo sind wir stehen geblieben hier?
Oh, Altersberechnung geht nicht. Das ist schon heftig.
Das die nicht nur versteht, nach was du fragst, sondern quasi das darauf beziehen kann,
auf das, was sie vorher geantwortet hat. Wobei der Fehler eher in JavaScript liegt,
das stimmt schon. Da kann die AI noch nichts dafür.
Und jetzt klappt die Berechnung auch.
Ich meine keine Ahnung. Muss man sich wundern, dass irgendwelche AI's irgendwann
mal versuchen werden, die Weltherrschaft zu übernehmen, wenn man sie den ganzen Tag
nach JavaScript fragt. Also den bleibt ja gar nichts anderes übrig, als den Wahnsinn abzustellen.
Möchtest du AI's, die die Menschheit auslöschen? Dann fragt sie den ganzen Tag nach JavaScript.
Und dann habe ich noch darum gebeten, einen animierten Sternenhimmel in den Hintergrund
zu packen. Und das macht Chat GPT auch.
Das ist schon heftig, oder?
Also ich kann ein bisschen HTML, aber ich kann absolut kein JavaScript.
Also ich hätte das aus dem Ärmel, also ich hätte das auch nicht aus dem Ärmel schütteln
können. Wisst ihr, was ich mir vorstellen kann?
Dass es demnächst Chat GPT Visual Studio Code Plugins gibt, so Art GitHub Code Pilot mäßig,
allerdings quasi als schnelleres Stack Overflow Interface.
Also für schnellere Antworten als auf Stack Overflow.
Weil die haben bestimmte Stack Overflow auch indiziert.
Chat GPT nicht hinbekommen, oder ich hätte wahrscheinlich mehrere Tage dafür gebraucht.
Chat GPT kann nicht nur programmieren, sondern auch Witze erzählen, Aufsätze schreiben und
seltsame Dinge erfinden. Bleibt dran.
Liebe Hackerinnen, liebe Internet- Was zum Teufel war das? Was das für eine Überleitung,
Alter?
Liebe Hackerinnen, liebe Internet- But why?
Warum zum Teufel musst du jetzt irgendwie halb durch das Bild fliegen?
Dieses Video wird gesponsert von AVM aus Berlin.
Jo, AVM hat mir gerade die neue Fritzbox 5590 Fiber geschickt und ich kriege wirklich direkt
deutlich mehr Durchsatz über WLAN, obwohl auch mein alter Router schon WIFI 6 hat, aber
halt nicht mit der 4x4 Antennenkonfiguration.
Erbung Ende.
Zuerst mal, was ist das überhaupt, Chat GPT?
Es handelt sich dabei um ein sogenanntes- Das ist innen bei den Jungen, ja aber der Typ
ist gar nicht so jung, der ist so alt wie ich oder so.
Ein großes Sprachmodell, also ein Large-Language-Model, also ein mit riesigen Textmengen trainiertes
Neuro-Language-Modell.
Also quasi ein richtiger 5-Hat-Albomus.
Wie ich detaillierter wissen wollte, wie sowas funktioniert, empfehle ich euch die CT-Ablink-Folge
über GPT-3.
Ja und GPT-3, das kommt von der gleichen Firma wie Chat GPT und das ist OpenAI.
OpenAI hat um es auch den Bildgenerator Dolly entwickelt und finanziert wird OpenAI unter
anderem von Elon Musk.
Von Microsoft?
Und Microsoft, ja.
Elon Musk.
Überall.
Jetzt sind wir am Start.
Ja.
Erstmal die Leute alle feuern bei OpenAI.
Die Zeit ist offen für alle und kostenlos.
Oh, oh, ich glaube es sollte keiner irgendwas zu Twitter oder Tesla fragen auf OpenAI, dann
ist gleich direkt Kündiger unterwegs.
Man muss allerdings einen OpenAI-Account anlegen und da Mail-Adresse und Handynummer angeben.
Während das ältere GPT-3 für Leute, die nicht coden können, noch etwas umständlich
zu bedienen war, ist Chat GPT jetzt so simpel wie Google.
Einfach eintippen, was man will und zack, Ergebnis.
Und anders als Google spuckt Chat GPT wirklich eine konkrete Antwort aus und nicht nur Links
auf andere Websites, wo man die Antwort vielleicht finden könnte.
Schaut mal hier.
Wenn ich Google frage...
Das coole ist halt, das ist das, was die ganzen alten Chatbots so auf dieser Website halt nicht
konnten.
Da hast du dann gefragt, wie sieht es mit meiner Bestellung aus und da hat er gesagt, ich sehe,
sie wollen was zum Thema Bestellungen wissen, hier ist ein Link auf ihre Bestellhistorie
oder irgendwie sowas.
Das war halt nichts.
Das ist jetzt schon eine ganze Ecke mehr advanced.
Warum der Himmel blau ist, dann kriege ich zwar direkt so eine hervorgehobene Antwort,
die bezieht sich aber nicht konkret auf meine Frage.
Jede Farbe hat eine andere Welle, ist auch ziemlich seltsam formuliert.
Chat GPT dagegen liefert mir eine konkrete Antwort und das Tolle ist, ich kann sogar
sagen, dass ich die noch einfacher haben will.
Der Himmel erscheint...
Open AI ist soweit, ich weiß Open.
Was glaube ich nicht Open ist, ist quasi das, was sie trainiert haben, also was sie mit
Open AI trainiert haben.
Wie nennt man das eigentlich, die trainierte AI oder so, die ist dann, die ist glaube ich
nicht Open.
Blau, weil das blaue Licht vom Sonnenlicht stärker gestreut wird, als die anderen Farben.
High IQ Antwort.
Das ist auf jeden Fall eine ganz gute einfache Antwort und wenn mir die zu einfach ist, bitte
ich um eine detailliertere Antwort.
Kann sogar Detailfragen stellen, zum Beispiel nach dem konkreten Wellenlängen, worauf
Chat GPT dann kontextbezogen antwortet.
Also Chat GPT merkt sich, worum es in den vorherigen Fragen ging und auch das kann Google nicht,
da muss ja jede Suchanfrage für sich stehen.
Also kann Google jetzt echt dicht machen mit ihrer Oldschool-Suchmaschine?
Nee, denn Chat GPT hat ein Problem und das sind die Fehler, die sich da immer wieder
einschleichen.
Hier zum Beispiel, da sagt Chat GPT, heise online wird von der heise Media Group betrieben.
Es gibt aber gar keine heise Media Group, es gibt nur die heise Medien GmbH und Co und
die heise Gruppe GmbH und Co.
Bei einer weiteren Anfrage haut Chat GPT einfach so locker raus, ich sei ein Kabarettist und
Musiker, der durch seine Musik-Comedy-Shows bekannt geworden ist.
Chat GPT, ich glaube bei dem Thema bin ich Experte und das stimmt nicht.
Das Ding ist, es reichen ja schon 5% Falschaussagen, um das ganze System ziemlich unbrauchbar zu
machen.
Denn man weiß ja dummerweise nicht, was genau falsch ist, wenn man sich mit einem Teamgebiet
eben nicht auskennt.
Das stimmt.
Bei Google gibt es natürlich auch Falschaussagen.
Aber das ist ja auch im Prinzip ein anderer Ansatz, Google indiziert ja das, was der Content
der vorhanden ist und gibt dir dann quasi einen Wegweiser, wo du das findest, was du
suchst, auf schon bestehendem Content.
Chat GPT baut für dich ja quasi aus einem trainierten Modell den Content neu zusammen.
Das sind ja zwei unterschiedliche Sachen, das muss man gar nicht so sehr vergleichen
eigentlich.
Aber da wird jetzt zumindest die Quelle angezeigt, man kann die Wahrheitswahrscheinlichkeit einigermaßen
einschätzen.
Ich warte schon drauf.
Ich sag's euch, die ganzen Manager sind jetzt hier am Frohlocken, weil sie endlich Webseiten
und Anwendungen selbst programmieren können und sie keine nervigen Programmierer brauchen,
die auch noch Geld dafür wollen.
Oder vielleicht auch mal die Vision infrage stellen oder sowas, was man sich dabei gedacht
hat.
Ich seh schon kommen, die ganzen Manager machen jetzt eigene Webseiten und Anwendungen
in Chat GPT, die dann irgendwie über kurz oder lang alle abkacken oder die übelsten
Probleme haben, was Sicherheit angeht oder halt schlicht und ergreifend nicht das machen,
was sie wollen.
Und dann bin ich mal gespannt, was passiert, ob man dann sagt, wir haben das richtig gemacht,
das ist ein gewolltes Feature oder sich eingesteht, dass Manager die Webseiten entwickeln doch
nicht so gut ist.
Im peer-reviewten wissenschaftlichen Paper kann man vermutlich ganz gut trauen, ein Tweet
von HONK auf Twitter eher nicht so.
Ja, und Chat GPT zeigt leider, wo die Informationen genau herkommen.
Das wäre ja auch schwierig.
Es wäre ja auch schwierig, da baut sich da ja aus zig indizierten Quellen Sachen zusammen.
Da kommen ja bestimmt auch von der Bedeutung ja komplett neue Sachen raus, die so im Original,
was die quasi sich einverleibt haben, in dem Model gar nicht drin waren.
Kann man wahrscheinlich so gar nicht mal eine Quelle dranschreiben, sondern auch in Programm
Code.
Am Anfang des Videos hatte ich euch ja schon den nicht funktionierenden Geburtstagsrechner
gezeigt.
Ich hatte sowas ähnliches schon beobachtet, als ich nach einer Website mit dem Bild eines
springenden Raspis gefragt hatte.
Beim ausgespucken Code waren die CSS Eigenschaften in einer Zeile falsch, weshalb das ganze Ding
nicht funktionierte.
Tja, aber ich habe dann Chat GPT seinen eigenen Code copy-pasted und gefragt, was daran falsch
ist.
Und Chat GPT hat dann tatsächlich den Fehler gefunden und korrigiert den Code ausgedrückt.
Das ist ziemlich cool, aber verlassen.
Der hat im Hintergrund wahrscheinlich einfach durch irgendein Paser, durch irgendein HTML
Paser laufen lassen oder so und festgestellt, ah, eine Zeile 35 ist ein Fehler, aber das
ist schon wirklich high IQ hier.
Kann man sich darauf nicht.
Ohnehin muss man natürlich sagen, dass das System noch in einem frühen Stadium ist und
deshalb noch ziemlich unzuverlässig arbeitet.
Viele Antworten brachen bei mir im Test mittendrin ab oder die Website funktionierte gar nicht
mehr.
Ich hatte auch schon, dass Chat GPT mir sagte, es könne gar kein Code generieren, obwohl
es das ja nun nachweislich schon ziemlich gut gemacht hat.
Außerdem habe ich ihm auch schon eine Argumentation entlockt, warum das CT-Magazin besser ist
als Linus Tech Tips und als ich das dann wiederholen wollte, kam nur so vorsichtiges Blabla, so
von wegen kann man ja nicht vergleichen.
Glamour, ich finde LTT natürlich genauso super wie das CT-Magazin, ich habe nur rumprobiert.
Ohnehin versucht Chat GPT sehr stark zu vermeiden, dass man den sogenannten Algorithmic Bias
erkennen kann, also diskriminierende oder rassistische Aussagen, die zweifellos im Trainingsmaterial
drinstecken.
Außerdem beantwortet es keine Fragen.
Oh Sariks, mich kennst du nicht.
Frag mal ob du das Wupplo auskennst.
Für illegale Aktivitäten.
Hä?
Was?
Wä?
Professionelle Hilfe.
Okay.
Auf Twitter popten immer mal wieder Work-Runs auf, wie man diese Sicherheitsfunktionen
außer Kraft setzen kann.
Diese Sicherheitslücken werden aber offenbar sehr schnell behoben, ich konnte jedenfalls
keine Bombenbauanleitung aus Chat GPT rausziehen.
Oh, da steht gleich die CIA vor der Tür sonst.
Hier meldet sich mal ganz kurz Keno aus der Zukunft, ich habe gerade noch was echt Verrücktes
ausprobiert.
Ich habe Chat GPT nämlich gesagt, er soll sich so verhalten wie ein Windows Terminal.
Das geht?
Das ist ja cool.
Chat GPT denkt sich ein Dateisystem aus, also irgendwelche Dateien die daraus sind, irgendwelche
IP-Adressen.
Es halluziniert also einen ganzen Computer.
Das ist, okay das ist keine VM, das ist quasi eine Phantom-VM oder sowas, ich weiß gar
nicht.
Nee, boah, da fällt mir doch kein Namen für einen.
Das ist abgefahren, oder?
So, jetzt wieder zurück zum Video.
Benehm dich wie Arschlinux, genau.
Chat GPT kann nämlich nicht nur Sachfragen beantworten, sondern auch kreativ sein.
Schau mal hier, denke dir lustige und kreative Namen für einen YouTube-Channel aus, der
sich mit Schokolade und Synthesizer beschäftigt.
Zack, und hey, Chocotron finde ich sogar echt gut, muss ich sagen, oder The Coco Keys auch.
Aber warum ist das auf Englisch auf einmal?
Aber kann man ja einfach sagen, Kommunikation ist wichtig in einer Beziehung.
Ja, und dann wird das Ganze ins Deutsche übersetzt und leider funktionieren die Wortspiele nicht
mehr so gut.
Zünderlecker, das stinkt fast schon eher unanständig.
Wir können ein Skript für ein Video dieses seltsamen YouTube-Kanals erfinden und ganz
ehrlich, das ist sogar einigermaßen charmant.
Während die Torte im Ofen ist, nehmen wir unsere Synthesizer und spielen einen süßen,
schokoladigen Soundtrack dazu.
Also ich glaube, ich würde mir das angucken.
Ja, und Chat GPT kann auch Kreativität und Sachinformation verbinden, zum Beispiel in
Form eines Essays.
Ich sehe es schon kommen, Leute.
Es gibt ja schon auf YouTube jede Menge so automatisch generierter Meme-Videos, seit
dem es YouTube Shorts gibt.
Die gehen im Hintergrund einfach auf irgendwelche Meme-Reddits und bauen daraus automatisiert
Videos mit Text-to-Speech und sowas.
Ich denke, ihr seid da auch schon über die ein oder anderen Videos gestolpert.
Also die eindeutig automatisch generiert wurden.
Ich könnte wetten, es gibt ja im nächsten YouTube-Videos, die rein darauf basieren.
Die haben dann irgendwelche krassen Titel und lesen dann quasi Inhalt von Chat GPT vor.
Okay, was sagt die zu mir?
Wo Bloss ist Twitch-Streamer und Content-Creator?
His real name is Max.
Hattet ihr das wirklich selbst so gesagt?
He hails from England, naja, playing various Battle Royale Games, naja, okay, hat keine
Ahnung.
Hier hatte ich übrigens gedacht, dass ich das System ein bisschen austricksen kann,
hat aber leider nicht funktioniert.
Er hat das gecheckt.
Aber trotzdem, wenn ich Lehrer wäre, würde ich vermutlich keine Aufsätze mehr als Hausaufgabe
aufgeben.
Das hier ist nämlich besser als das, was ich in der neunten Klasse zustande gebracht
hätte.
Da kann man es unmöglich als Plagiat erkennen, denn es ist ja kein Plagiat.
Ja, und mit Rückwärtssuche findest du da auch nichts.
Ein zwar KI-generierter, aber ein Originaltext.
Vor der Abgabe drüber lesen sollte man aber, dass Martin Luther das, was er da an die Tür
genagelt hat, 95 Theses genannt hat, naja, das hätte ich vermutlich auch in der neunten
Klasse schon gecheckt.
Kurioserweise kennt Chat GPT den echten Originaltitel der 95 Thesen, aber offenbar hat es manchmal
Erinnerungslücken oder so.
Was Chat GPT übrigens überhaupt nicht kann, ist Humor.
Das kommt raus, als ich nach einem Witz gefragt habe, in dem Martin Luther ein Raspberry
Pie und ein Schokoladenkuchen vorkommt.
Einmal traf sich Martin Luther mit einem Raspberry Pie und einem Schokoladenkuchen in einer Kirche.
Der Raspberry Pi sagte, Martin Luther, du hast die Reformation gestartet und dafür
sollten wir einen Schokoladenkuchen essen.
Martin Luther antwortete, ich hab doch schon meine 95 Thesen an die Kirchestür geschlagen.
Ich glaube, das reicht für heute.
Der Raspberry Pie und der Schokoladenkuchen sahen sich enttäuscht an und gingen dann
ohne Martin Luther weg.
Ahja.
Ja.
Also mein Fazit, der Chat GPT ist wirklich ein extrem beeindruckendes Werkzeug.
Der Witz war so schlecht, dass er schon irgendwie lustig war.
...ziemlich sicher in irgendeiner Form in unseren Alltag einziehen wird.
Alleine die Fähigkeit, präzise auf konkrete Fragen zu antworten, ist wirklich hilfreich
und das Erstellen von Code auf Basis von normaler Sprache, ja, das ist auch ganz klar was, was
Leute künftig benutzen werden und natürlich auch das Korrigieren von eigenen Codeschnipseln.
Wo OpenAI allerdings noch nacharbeiten muss, sind die sporadisch auftretenden Fehler.
Das wäre wichtig, dass man zumindest einen Hinweis drauf hätte, welche Aussagen man
nochmal manuell nachprüfen sollte.
Und zum Abschluss noch ein von Chat GPT geschriebenes Gedicht, was sich laut Chat GPT auch reimt.
CT 3003 ist ein Kanal, der's faustdick hat.
Abonniere ihn, sonst wirst du's bereuen.
Neues Video?
Kein Problem.
Klick auf die Glocke, dann bist du's, der's sieht.
Ahja.
Okay.
Tschüss.
So sieht's also aus.
Jetzt wissen wir Bescheid, oder?
Was haben wir sonst noch?
Wollen wir uns noch das Fireship Video dazu angucken?
Komm wir gucken uns doch, wenn wir Chat schon mal im Thema sehen, gucken wir noch Fireship
hinterher.
Ich bin schon seit Jahren versucht, euch das zu bemerken, Artificial Intelligence ist
in der Zeit, Programmer zu verändern.
Over den letzten wenigen Tagen hat die Welt über Chat GPT gefeiert, eine neue Demo
von OpenAI, die Kode schreiben und analysieren kann, betreffend viele andere Sachen.
Die Artikel selbst ist sehr beeindruckend, aber sie wird nicht Programmers verändern.
Sie können wirklich nur triviale Probleme lösen, wie GitHub Copilot und oft gibt es Antworten,
die einfach falsch sind, aber auch korrekt nach jemandem, ohne die richtige Domainwissen.
Es wurde bereits von Stackoverflow verbreitet, weil das Site...
Basiert Github CodePilot eigentlich auf der gleichen Technik?
Ich glaube schon, oder?
Also, bevor ich schreibe, schreibe ich lieber netstet-tulben und guck was läuft. Oder crept nach 1018. Aber gut, ich gette die Idee dahinter.
Und stop it! Die Sache ist halt die, ich würde mich auf einen Produktionsserver nicht darauf verlassen, dass diese Erkennung automatisch und korrekt immer funktioniert.
Stell dir mal vor, ich sag stop it und der denkt in dem Kontext, ah ja Server runterfahren.
Boah, das wird ja Sicherheitslücken als Fakt geben.
Das ist aber kein korrektes UML-Diagramm. So geht das aber nicht. Also das würde die IAK in der Abschlussprüfung nicht durchgehen lassen.
Ja, dafür sollte man AI verwenden für nochmal JavaScript-Frameworks. Das ist eine gute Idee.
Woop, lost JS. Woop, JS.
Ich hoffe, das ist alles in Raspolk kommet.
In 2050.
Wahrscheinlich transpilen wir dann JavaScript in WebAssembly oder so Dinger.
Die sind ja nie sich zu schade abgedrehte Sachen auszudenken, was Web-Technologien angeht.
Was mach ich denn heute? Mach ich jetzt MMO-Grind? Baue ich den Rechner zusammen? Wobei Rechner zusammenbauen hab ich ja gesagt, mach ich im Stream.
Dann muss ich jetzt eine Runde MMO-Grind machen. Ich könnte auch meine Steuererklärung fertig machen.
Aber ich glaube, dann grind ich lieber eine Runde MMO. Geschlafen hab ich die ganze Nacht.
Welches MMO? Ein 20 Jahre altes uralt MMO.
Auf einem FreeShot auch noch.
Massive Graphics.
Was das für Musik war? Das war Crypt of the Necrodancer Soundtrack.
Cadence ist auch ganz schön dick geworden in der Nintendo-Variante.
Was hieß das? Hyrule Cadence? Das war so ein Zelda-Style-Ableger davon. Mit dem gleichen Hauptcharakter, nur dass sie da irgendwie doppelt so dick ist.
Wolltest du nicht noch einen Google-Cloud-Terraform-Stream machen? Das ist richtig. Nur mit dem Unterschied, dass ich keine Zeit hab gerade.
Hier muss ich auch noch einen 4er-Chap bauen.
Es gibt ein neues Dwarf Fortress. Das Game ist 20 Jahre alt. Jetzt mit halbwegs ordentlicher Grafik.
Was können wir uns sonst noch angucken?
Ein Entwickler reißt jetzt bestimmt voll raus, obwohl die doch angeblich noch mit dem gesamten Team dran sitzen und das Ganze fixen.
Ich bekomme Vollstack-Diable, aber das sind Mikroservice-Überwände.
Was ist eigentlich aus Artikel 13 geworden?
Das ist ein Internet-Halbunter.
Die sind wegen verbotener Memes festgenommen.
Es erinnert mich ein bisschen an Internet-Historien von der Aufmachung her.
Was? Oh nee. Kenne den noch? Kenne den Dude noch? Das wie hieß der? Voss oder so? Ja, Axel Voss, genau.
Oh nein.
Das ist ein Kurs, für den dann 2 Jahre später abgestimmt werden soll.
Ja, soweit die Idee. Wozu es geführt hat, ist, dass bei YouTube extrem viel overblockt wird mittlerweile.
Das klingt eigentlich ganz fair und zu der Zeit hat das Thema abseits vom EU-Parlament auch keinen so richtig gejuckt.
Doch was man nicht beachtete war, dass alles, was auch nur ansatzweise ähnlich wirkt, somit aufgesperrt wurde. Und dasselbe gilt auch für die Memes.
Die ersten paar Artikel über das bevorstehende Europa-Meme-Verbot. Und Leute bekamen mit davon und waren nicht erfreut.
Du wohnst, Junge!
Das finde ich ja geil!
Das finde ich ja geil, wie sie das nachgebaut haben mit dem Lego.
Pfeifett!
Doch auch wenn die zahlreichen Versuche Europa zu bannen, damit ein Europa 2 entsteht, an viel Reichweite gewann, waren die Mühlen leider erfolglos. Und man versuchte natürlich wieder Geld mit dem Hype zu machen, aber gut. Und somit kam die Nachricht doch langsam in Deutschland an. Und so fing ein kleiner deutscher Kreis an, Leute an Flyer zu verteilen, um Leute auf die bevorstehende Tensur aufmerksam zu machen. Wirklich viele Flyer. Und die allerersten kleinen Protesten wurden auch ins Leben gerufen.
Und es klappte. Am 5. Juli 2018 wurde der erste Gesetzesentwurf abgelehnt.
Ja, das heißt ja nicht, dass es dabei geblieben wäre, ne?
Wir haben es geschafft! Ich kann es nicht glauben!
Die originalen Memes wurden gesichert und konnten in Frieden weiter existieren. Doch eine Person war darüber gar nicht glücklich. Und zwar CDU-Politiker Marcel Voss.
Da ist er ja!
Er setzt sich für das neue Gesetz ein und ist Experte in Sachen Internet. Er ist der gefürchtete Slayer der Memes.
Er ist genauso Experte im Internet wie der Oettinger damals.
Und so stand der nächste Verhandlungstermin vor der Tür.
In my home country Baden-Württemberg, we say we are all sitting in one boat.
Voller Eifer das Internet zu retten. Und so schicken sie Briefe an Vorsitzende im Parlament mit der Hoffnung, sie umzustimmen.
Als interessiert das Parlament irgendjemand, ob da irgendwie der 0815-Dude ihn schreibt.
Die größte europäische Petition am Politiker übergeben und der nächste Abstimmungstag war gekommen.
Das EU-Parlament stückte diesmal FÜR das neue Memesentführungsgesetz.
Jetzt wo es mehr Widerstand gibt, muss man natürlich zustimmen.
Und guckt euch an, wie fies ein Handtuch fiel. Denn an diesem Tag war die erste Schlacht verloren. Und mit ihr fiel ein Stück Meinungsfreiheit im Internet.
Der hat sich jetzt gefreut, jawoll! Alle meine Klienten sind glücklich.
Wir haben versagt.
Ich kriege wieder Geld.
Ein Politiker im Parlament kritisierte sogar die Wahl. Naja.
Ein enormer Streit gegen die Freiheit der Rede auf dem Internet.
Ein anderes Parlamentsmitglied namens Count Jankula sagte daraufhin, dass man merkt, dass die Politiker absolut keine Ahnung haben, für was sie da eigentlich voten und ihre Broser wahrscheinlich so aussehen.
Fun Fact, er wurde mal verurteilt, weil er seinem Hund den Hitler-Gust beigebracht hat.
Sieg Heil!
Das ist eine andere Story.
What?
In einer störenden Niederlage lud der offizielle YouTube-Kanal ein Video hoch, wie sie zeigten, wie das Internet bald aussehen könnte.
Und somit wurde der Mainstream das erste Mal so richtig auf das Thema aufmerksam.
Artikel 13.
Bald explodiert mein Kleiderschrank.
No!
Somit angeschieht noch eine Vielzahl an unterstützenden Creator, aber auch YouTuber, die einfach nur Panik machten und ihre Free Clicks abstauben wollten.
Das könnte YouTube morgen sein.
Warum unser Kanal nächstes Jahr wahrscheinlich gelöscht wird und es ist auch kein Klickband.
Nein, nein, nein, oder so kein Klicksbait.
Es ist leider kein Klickbait.
Also es ist kein Klickbait.
Aber nein, Leute, das ist wirklich kein Scherz.
Das ist wirklich real shit.
Gleich kommt noch ApoRed.
Excuse me, what the fuck.
Doch wie soll das Gesetz eigentlich in der Praxis aussehen?
Axel Forst und sein Team hatten eine geniale Idee.
Der Upload-Filter.
Ein böser Cyberhacker mit Kapuze und Anonymous-Maske legt Despacito auf YouTube hoch und schreibt dahinter mein neuer Song-XD.
Der Upload-Filter soll das verhindern, bevor er überhaupt hochgeladen wird.
Und der Despacito-Mann kriegt das Geld, was ihm zusteht.
Und jetzt, wie es dann wirklich aussehen würde.
Man baut in seinem YouTube-Video einen South Park-Clip ein.
Versuchst du gerade etwa illegal die Serie hochzuladen?
Video gesperrt.
Du postest ein Meme im Internet und es ist auf seinem Musikvideo.
Bild gesperrt.
Dein heißes Pick auf Tinder.
Cooles Gemälde im Hintergrund.
Gehört dir nicht?
Bild gesperrt.
Du lädst ein Foto auf Insta hoch.
Mit Käse in der Hand.
Versuchst du gerade etwa die Mona Lisa hochzuladen?
Es ist nicht möglich.
Man müsste wirklich alles präventiv sperren lassen.
Ja, man hat aber eine Sache gesehen auf YouTube.
Also vieles wird ja präventiv gesperrt.
Ich wollte ein Video hochladen letztens.
Ich überlege, warte mal, ich konnte das Ganze dann hochladen.
Wobei das wahrscheinlich jetzt, ich weiß nicht,
nur am Rande was mit dieser Sache zu tun hat.
Hier.
Und das Ding hat immer das X-Hamster-Logo erkannt.
Erst als ich da so einen komischen Hamster davor platziert habe,
dass das X leicht verdeckt ist, dann hat er erkannt, okay.
Anscheinend ist es nicht so, doch nicht so schlimm.
Dann gleich so, nope, nein, das war nicht so schlimm.
Das war nicht so schlimm.
Dann gleich so, nope, das darfst du hier nicht hochladen.
War das nicht das, wo sie gesagt haben,
eine Kontrolle auf der Straße oder war das was anderes?
Ach ja, echt?
Ja, richtige Internet-Experte, der Axel.
Echte Experte.
Der hat einen typischen Gesichtsausdruck, was mache ich hier?
Was ist das hier?
Krasser Dude.
Währenddessen begannen auf den Straßen die ersten großen Demonstrationen
und plötzlich zeigten sich auch die ersten Verbünde.
Wikipedia setzte die Seite für einen ganzen Tag für alle als Protest offline.
Wie soll ich jetzt meine Hausaufgaben machen?
Ich esse jetzt die Tastatur.
Genauso wie Reddit.
Und die Maus esse ich auch.
Und Pornup, Twitch und Patreon machten auf den RTK 13 Aufmerksam.
Gleichzeitig bildete sich eine Gegenpartei mit Hashtag Yes to Copyright.
Zum Großteil waren das große Firmen und Lobby-Unternehmen,
die davon profitieren.
Zumal du vorher schon richtige Probleme hast, ja?
Wenn du in der Innenstadt rumgelaufen bist, hast du was aufgenommen,
im Hintergrund lief Last Christmas, BÄM!
Das war ja schon vorher problematisch.
Aber von den Leuten Demos, die deutlich größer waren als die Artikel 13 Demos.
Jawoll!
Wir sind in der Oberstadt!
Währenddessen war Großbritannien stark darum bemüht, die EU zu verlassen,
damit sie weiter Shit posten können.
Und so nahmen die Artikel 13 Demos langsam ihren Lauf.
Und mit dabei waren auch einige große Namen und YouTuber,
die für die Meinungsfreiheit kämpfen.
Manche waren ein bisschen weniger engagiert und manche auch ein bisschen mehr.
Und am 23.4. wird es richtig abgehen!
Gemeinsam dafür, dass Artikel 13 beerdigt wird!
Gleichzeitig gab es ein Artikel 13 Tape-Challenge auf Instagram.
Na ja, der gute Wille zählt.
Und Shoutout an den Boy, der zum EU-Parlament gefahren ist,
um dort Meme-Banger zu geben.
Wie hieß der nochmal?
Von dem habe ich Davy... Davy... Davy 504? Kann das sein?
505, 505, ja, irgendwie so.
Doch 504 habe ich doch recht, ja.
Oder Dave 504, nicht Davy, doch Davy.
Die Demos waren riesig und Axel Force tauchte unter.
Denn der Druck auf ihn wurde immer größer.
Doch plötzlich bekam Axel Force Unterstützung von anderen CDU-Mitgliedern.
Zum Beispiel Daniel Kaspari.
Er kam auf eine geniale Theorie.
Die Demonstranten sind gar nicht vor Ort, weil sie das wollen,
sondern wurden von der USA mit 450 Euro pro Person bezahlt.
Und so tweetete er seine unglaublich durchdachte Theorie.
Das kam natürlich ziemlich gut an.
Und daraufhin schrieben Leute Mails und fragten,
wo denn ihre 450 Euro an Demo-Geld sein.
450 Euro.
You guys are getting paid?
Axel Force selber war auch der Meinung,
dass die Kampagnen aus den USA gesteuert werden.
CDU-Mitglied Sven Schulze sagte,
dass die besorgten E-Mails, die er bekommen hat, doch nur bot zu sein.
Peribert Törte diskutierte mit Juven auf Twitter.
Man sieht alles äußerst junge und technisch erfahrene Leute,
die dazu was sagen.
Die haben wirklich Ahnung.
Wenn ich mir einen Internet-Experten
oder generell digitale Medien-Experte vorstelle,
dann sieht er eindeutig so aus wie Peribert Törte.
Wenn das für Sie ein Totschlag-Argument ist,
würde ich auch gerne meinen Hut in den Ring werfen.
Dann gab es noch den Fall,
dass Politiker einfach gesagt haben,
dass sie gegen Artikel 13 voten,
aber in der Vergangenheit dafür gestimmt haben,
nur um damit die jungen Kids abzuholen.
Die CDU selber war währenddessen auch damit,
Uploadfilter zu stoppen,
um die jungen Wähler für sich zu gewinnen.
Und Merkel wusste währenddessen gar nicht so richtig,
um was es geht.
Christian Lindner hingegen traf sich mit Pete Smith
und setzte sich gegen die kommenden Filter ein.
Gleichzeitig kam raus,
dass Presseverlage mit schlechter Berichterstattung
über die Politiker durften,
die gegen Artikel 13 stimmten.
Ah ja, man kämpft also mit unfairem Mittel.
Doch die Niemlaws ließen sich nicht unterkriegen.
Und somit erreichten die Demos ihre volle Macht
mit einer Teilnehmerzahl von durchschnittlich 30.000 Leuten.
Und das allererste Mal kämpfen alle Teile des Internets
die Redditor, die Twitter-User,
Minecrafter, Cosplayer, die Niemlaws,
die Beauty-Girls, die Goths,
sogar die introvertierten waren da.
Und mit den immer so verwertenden Demos...
Ich nicht.
...ist auch die Anzahl an verschiedenen Protestschildern.
Wütender Bruder, bin fassungslos.
Axel Voss fickt das Internet.
Der Apple-Filter betrifft übrigens auch Bonnet.
Liebe, leckerlich.
Axel Voss fickt das Internet mit dem Bild dabei.
Statt Artikel 13.
Save my handheld.
Suche Bots zum den Lurys reinhämmen.
Ich schwöre, ich bin kein Roboter.
Subscribe to PewDiePie.
Die CDU versteht so viel vom Internet.
Wie ich vom Laufen.
Destroy my pussy, not the Internet.
Ich schwöre, letzte Woche Kunst-LK war so geil.
Okay, Jungs, reicht jetzt langsam auch.
Wo ist hier das Klo?
Ein paar Leute haben sich sogar als Roboter verkleidet.
Und auch auf musikalischer Ebene
versuchte man Artikel 13 ein Ende zu setzen.
Während die Amerikaner auf Reddit
überdurchschnittlich oft Axel Voss mit Hitler
verglichen, kam der Mann sogar seinen eigenen
Hate-Hashtag. Und der Tag zur
finalen Abstimmung rückte näher.
Es war klar, nur einer würde gewinnen.
Axel Voss oder die Memes.
Alter, wie lang haben die gebraucht, um das zu schneiden?
Axel, was ist los?
Hast du wieder diese Alpträume?
Komm, leg dich hin.
Die Abstimmung ist mort.
Worauf ich hinaus will, Axel Voss wurde zu dieser
Zeit unglaublich stark gehasst.
Und das auch zu der Zeit,
in der sie sich um die Alpträume
verbreitet haben.
Und das auch zu der Zeit,
in der sie sich um die Alpträume verbreitet haben.
Und das auch zu ihrer Zeit,
Obnormie werden die Seelteuer hier.
eta heute
Warte,
flute
haben,
Text wurde angenommen
Und somit wurden auch die Memes für immer ausgelöscht oder auch nicht
Ja, okay das ist offensichtlich nicht passiert erstmal kam raus dass sich zwei leute aussehen verklickt haben und die meisten immer noch nicht
ganz so sollte die leute stimmen da drüber ab einer
Die nicht mal links und rechts richtig klicken können für sie überhaupt abstimmen das internet war empört über das
Ergebnis und der kampf um die memes schien verloren doch dann kamen die leuten auf reddit eine geniale idee wir lagen hitler reden hoch mit
copyright geschützter musik dann müsste man das sperren und
macht geld mit nazi propaganda das wiederum ist illegal in deutschland
Die EU wird sich somit selber vernichten und die 13 wird beerdigt und seitdem gibt es kein artikel 3
herausgestellt hat sich das artikel 13 nach einer langjährigen untersuchung gegen das grundrecht der meinungsfreiheit
verstößt und somit verfassungswidrig ist
Zusammengefasst man sich dann immer denkt
Haben die sich da vorher nicht mal beraten lassen als sowas beschlossen wurde oder hat man sich beraten lassen wusste das hat es aber trotzdem
durchgedrückt
Auf welcher auf welchen interessen beruhen auch immer was idee war von anfang an zum schalten
verurteilt und deshalb wurde bisher nur eine sehr verharmloste vision von artikel 13 eingeführt
wo nur zum beispiel komplett hochgeladene film im internet oder ähnliches gesperrt werden kann und die cdu wurde später dann bei der europawahl
komplett massakriert und der hoferrat der eu an der jüngeren generation wird bis heute nicht vergessen doch die geschichte ist noch nicht ganz
endet denn es ist ein neues gesetz im gespräch die chatkontrolle die eu soll alle nachrichten überwachen kindesmissbrauch und terroranschläge zu wissen
die holen immer die gleichen sachen raus wenn es darum geht es kommt immer kindesmissbrauch
terrorismus bekämpfung und sowas immer egal was da sowas
bei diesen immer diese zwei sachen terrorismus
Terrorismus mord und kindesmissbrauch ein fbi agent mitlesen wenn ich in zehn von zehn
Mien versende mein fbi agent wenn er mich beim zwanzigsten recap schaffens der scheitern sieht und jetzt ratet mal wer sich für diese chatkontrolle
einsetzten mark ford es ist es ist wieder axel ford ist er wieder am start
Wo ist der du überhaupt noch da man na gut weil die niemand direkt dahin wählt
Oh man ja aber ich kann mich noch dran erinnern als mit artikel 13 das internet unterging
Oh man
Ja die leute hast du immer die wählen schon immer die gleiche partei und wählen dann auch weiterhin
Ich habe immer das problem ich habe echt keine ahnung wie nicht wählen soll
ich finde alle zum größten teils scheiße das heißt zum größten teils ich finde alle scheiße
und keine ahnung aber nicht wählen gehen ist auch blöde idee aber das kannst du dann im endeffekt
bist du dann quasi rausgerechnet wenn du so willst also es gilt dann für alle aber die prozente
werden verteilt ohne dass du was dazu gesagt hast wie heißt das video von dem das ist von
jules artikel als artikel 13 das internet zerstören wollte
die videos sind alle gut ok wir gucken jetzt nicht noch als ich gucke mal was
er sonst noch so hat als pokemon go die welt eroberte der pixel krieg um a place
der da kann ich mich noch dran erinnern großes schiff steckt fest
das hat so ein bisschen internet historian vibes aber auf deutsch
oder habt ihr nicht auch denn das sind das gefühl gehabt beim gucken
jep pock
Wie läuft's ihr Job, Schelz?
Erzähl ich nächste Woche was zu.
Nächste Woche Mittwoch entscheidet sich's dann endgültig.
Heute noch Wander?
Heute nicht, Sonntag ist der einzige Tag wo ich manchmal nicht gehe, oder vielleicht
heute Nachmittag, mal gucken.
Gibt's zu futtern?
Ich glaub ich hab noch Nudeln, ich hab immer noch Nudeln übrig sonntags, das sag ich glaub
ich die letzten drei Monate schon, was gehst du denn an Nudeln?
Gehst du immer vor oder nach, danach, danach.
Das einzige was ich morgens manchmal mache, ist ich nur bis zum Südbahnhof laufe und ich
laufe dann so eine halbe Stunde noch nach Frankfurt in die Innenstadt, aber ansonsten
immer abends.
Heute Abend PC baustehen, weiß ich nicht, wenn ich nicht zu sehr immer im Ukraine Stels
mache.
Mal gucken.
Okay Leute, wir sehen uns, ich geh mal futtern, ich hab jetzt schon Hunger.
11.20.
Wir sehen uns, wir sehen uns, bis denn, see you.